and we are live the last word with laura
cogdino and ibontis and thai guy travis
with that special guest time of friday
morning first gentlemen how are we doing
so what he bounces uh been very busy
playing a lot of games working through
dark souls and nobody saves the world
about two-thirds through both of those
so actually really enjoying those crazy
week of news trying not to take too long
the intro travis go
hi i'm mcclunkey
that's all that's all
comments
all right read my review dying light too
much lucky yo yeah please actually read
that before you jump on something yeah
please check that out check it out deal
james [ __ ] what's going on yup you
already know me incognito so much news
to talk about and we gotta just get into
it but before we get into all of that
e
we have some royalty here
yes all right
episode number 183 just when you think
gaming news was done
next week says hold my beer one of these
the biggest indies in the world is now
under the sony umbrella and each nugget
of information that comes out about this
deal is more unique than than it seems
to be
we got teased with exotics zombie
parkour is back in the mainstream and we
have one heck of a thick boy twab to say
the least
thank you [ __ ]
okay we gotta get back
with such an effort to show off those
tree trunks such an epic pieces piece of
news how could we have a chat around the
campfire without a truly epic guest
it is fitting that bungie is now in the
sony family because that this is where
this game this man's gaming journey
started at age six with a little game
that some of us may know called rayman
a variety of games were mixed in the
middle but xbox 360 and halo is where
gaming became something more than just a
hobby what some of us call an addiction
competition runs deep in this gentleman
and proof of that is shown when he was
number
taste for content creation and gaming
was life so he strapped his youtube
channel to the back of the division and
rose to the top in very short order
always critical when needed but fair in
his judgments hilarious when trying new
content but also sometimes crying
through that laughter and while the
vision hasn't fared that well he has
traded breaking off armor parts to
matching weapon colors in destiny 2. so
let's welcome i feel like i'm about to
fight someone here like i'm just being
hyped up in the ring
so let's welcome one of the few people
to actually beat both the division raid
and a destiny raid has a youtube channel
with over 450 000 youtube subscribers
and hailing from the country with the
tallest men in the world the one the
only marco style and i'm gonna try and
do this hoodie morgan
what what was that i was trying to say
he's trying to say goodbye
good morning good morning he's from he's
from europe i'm from texas
i tried and it sucked so anyway welcome
to our wonderful campfire how you doing
this morning or afternoon for you
there was so much with that intro but
the thing that struck me most is that
you called um
that you called bungie an indie dev
studio
right did i catch that right yeah
anymore yeah not anymore not anymore but
uh yeah i was just i had to think about
that joke where every time blizzard
would [ __ ] something up people already
would always say oh it's just a small
indie in the company or whatever it's
kind of the same for destiny but yeah
you can't say it anymore now
oh yeah i'm doing great i guess a little
bit tired but i guess we all are here
uh a little lack of sleep
a little bit here we appreciate you man
especially the guy
underneath me
if i see that right on the stream you
have a guy underneath you
[Laughter]
let's get right into it man for me you
know i know we he kind of touched on
your gaming history i usually go there
first but i'm gonna pivot because
i have come to know you
as the division guy right when i'm
always a hardcore destiny guy we me and
e used to have about to have these
discussions during the division ii and
anthem launches as competitors to
destiny right so me i was the one that
said
yo division is the one you got to watch
you know long tail they're doing raids
you know at the time that was my
thinking travis fix your face so at the
end of the day i was just like you know
that's the one long term and i would
religiously go to marco stout child so
to see your journey as a content creator
i have to ask this like
it's for us for me it would be the
equivalent of datto
then leaving and going hardcore to
another game so i just want to get with
the division love first and then the
actual thing that broke you to shift to
destiny
yeah i guess um
so it's it's a pretty long story but i
guess i'll just give you the very short
version of it
uh
at some point even before the vision
came out i i knew that i wanted to do
something with youtube and the vision
just seemed like a very interesting game
to me
because at the time i was very much
interested in games like grand theft
auto uh and from that very first trailer
it kind of looked like a sword over
grand theft auto not really but it had
some of those elements and i was like
okay you know what let's just see if i
can find out some news on this game so i
like i started uploading those type of
videos
and then two things happened i
i got bigger as the game launched and i
actually found myself playing a game
that i really enjoyed so it was like a
somewhat a perfect match
but
i mean division one at launch was far
from perfect it had so many falls and
over the years uh like
i've tried so so much to kind of push
the game in the right direction as you
would expect a dado of destiny to do yes
yes
like i'm sure datto has posted so many
videos so far he would like to see uh
you know bungie take destiny next and in
some cases they might have listened and
in some other cases they might have not
right
uh they and and that's
i guess i did the same with the division
there
um
and
i don't know at some point division two
came out it was very obvious they
weren't working on division one anymore
right and
with division two
they
changed so much so much in a direction
of what like a lot of people didn't want
from the game
uh and as i was playing that i just felt
like i wasn't enjoying myself now this
might also be because i just grew out of
it a little bit
like i i know it's a lot of hours to to
a lot of people because i know some
people play crazy amount of hours video
games yes yes but uh
i mean i played like two to three
thousand hours of division one that's no
joke and that's over the course of like
three years so it's not like it's not
that crazy it's not that much it's not
an insane amount
but i would feel like it might have been
that's a lot i mean because you should
feel bad that's a lot i've got 25.
did you play the division i played the
division one that game had like it's 40
hours of content so if you played 2 000
hours you played that content a lot
well no no most of the content came from
the dark zone and actually playing pvp
of course
that's i could never play those missions
for like even 1000 hours but i know that
like if it's like your full-time thing
then even that can be seen it's not a
lot of hours right so i know it's not
that much but i think i just grew out of
it
and then they changed up the formula so
much in division two while also not
having like a polished game whatsoever
sounds like another game i know another
sequel
yes destiny too yeah a little bit
uh and and it was just such a gut bunch
um
that and i just didn't enjoy the game so
at some point i was like okay well i'm
obviously making good money with this so
i can keep doing this kind of like that
oh i feel like dada was also a bit
burned out on destiny he's is more than
past that point i don't want to speak
for him or anything
i feel like he's expressed that in his
videos and so i kind of was at the point
where he was and and maybe a bit further
because i just maybe wasn't feeling the
game as much anymore
um
and so i just said okay well i can
either you know milk this out or i can
think about the super long term and and
see what actually would make me happy uh
and see if i can challenge myself to do
something new
so then i made a whole bunch of
different um
videos uh some of them
just completely random i don't even
remember right now i'd have to look back
at what i released at the time rainbow
six siege for example
like a whole bunch of other stuff some
did some split gate then i made a
destiny video as well and uh
and at first i i didn't really enjoy
destiny because it seemed like
just another looter shooter i mean
obviously uh the game feels good to play
but the chord was just another lunar
shooter with not much substance to it
even making a build in that game is so
much
less
yeah so like if you compare that to uh
the division the division if you made a
good build it was like a day of a
difference respect destiny you get like
a little bit of range you get like a
couple shorter cooldowns like wow crazy
right like
it wasn't like that appealing like you
can pop your super like two minutes
earlier wow that's
so that wasn't really
that special to me
and so my first destiny video actually
said yeah i can see why people enjoy it
feels smooth but i don't think i'm going
to be playing this long term either
because i just be swift shifting the
issue right playing one loader shooter
and i'm playing another but then
wow like some streamers uh especially
glad and like fami from redeem um they
actually invited me to do a couple raids
with them and i think that was because
i think that was because i actually
helped glad out with a raid in division
two because i think he had a lot of a
lot of trouble clearing that rate yeah
everybody the first rate of the division
two
right and then i think we jumped in a
couple hours to help him before i i
really had to go because i think it was
the night after i got world's first and
i've been up all night and like i had to
do some stuff already
you saw that
i got carried i definitely got married i
definitely got carried thank you
show us the belt and show us the man
underneath there was a reward for it but
i was actually so fed up with destiny 2
or division 2 at the time that i didn't
email them to collect rewards because i
didn't care that much so i just yeah
that's like such a waste of rewards i
just never claimed it because i just i
was just there for the for the ride you
know get carried for the title and then
just dip oh you was done
yeah i was i was like i think that was
um
i think the speed room for that raid uh
a part with uh like a site with the
tutorials on how to beat each encounter
were pretty much the last division
videos i uploaded
uh yeah actually now i look at my
channel there was one more that came
like a little bit later but it's pretty
much the last video so i uploaded
because i was so done with the game at
the time
somebody wanted me to ask you is sleep
he's still alive yeah steven studios
yeah yeah yeah i just talked to him
today
we were just we're trying to set up a
decent rate squad for day one of which
screen because i do want to get back
into raiding like i know i haven't
played
a very long time and but sleepy's still
been active here and there and i you
know we're setting stuff up
nice um
d flawless
[Music]
so after i got invited by glad um and
and friends by the way um
i got pulled into a couple rates uh most
notably the last uh wish rate nice and
and that is
and he made us like do a blind figure
everything out ourselves i sat there for
like the whole 12 13 hours of course
they helped us a bit during the dps
phases
like they they let us fail a good amount
of times like more than you would let
somebody
like more than if you were to just carry
or take someone through it but then
when he realized that if we got it fully
figured out but we just didn't have the
guns then they would just like carry us
through like a solid two phase or
whatever right so
uh and and that was like
such a cool experience like the raids
in destiny they are so good
especially and and i guess that is that
is what got me to fall in love with
destiny too and then ever since then my
only goal with destiny has just been to
blindly play every rate and then play
every raid and dungeon that comes out
like that's the reason i still come back
to which screen right now as well like i
want to play the raid i want to do it
day one because that's an experience you
can't really get in any other game
ever pretty much right can you repeat
that statement as a division a former
division can you repeat that last
sentence because a lot of people don't
realize that about ladies
he wants to collect this and send it to
all of his divisions
in destiny you can't find that anywhere
else in any other video game
and it's just such a unique experience
especially the day one right like it's
all different
and that's
so and that's why i stuck with destiny
too so even to this day i don't really
care about min maxing builds in destiny
2 i don't really care about all that i
just
i'm just coming to destiny for these
experiences and somehow i've actually
managed to make enough content with that
to survive on youtube for another two or
two years and just take it in a whole
other direction nice um
salute man i definitely i just want to
do it i know i went off a little bit
he forgive me but i had to ask him this
my limited time so i had to ask him that
and you know because again he's one of
the top division content creators i go
to his content all the time and it was
an interesting thing to me to see that
and i was just like wow i've never seen
anything like that before like the
person who's the connoisseur of one game
and goes there and i guess the final
thing and then i'll open it up to the
last two i know how long was that is
there anything division can do to bring
you back because i know they have a late
later like road map potential content
and the other thing was
three i know a lot of people in division
community the vibe i get they were
frustrated that they didn't listen you
know what i'm saying so what i believe
was a massive guy what the name oh they
listened i think to say that the
developers didn't listen it's very much
unfair there's countless of times where
i like in-depth dms with developers and
they would actually take some of my
changes
i was flown out i was flown over to
their studio for like a like a program
where i would play like
unreleased builds for like a week
straight and like sit a round table with
like to say that they didn't listen is
is just not true okay it's just that
um
like i honestly don't know there's just
some things i guess that they didn't
agree with or some things that couldn't
be pushed for certain builds and some
things that weren't high priority enough
and and and to be fair a lot of those
things might have not been that high
priority
uh to the overall player base it's just
that for players like me those things
were pretty important so it's like
uh they definitely try to listen i
definitely i don't want to say any like
bad things there uh because that would
just be not true right like that's fair
that's fair that's fair
and that's
i mean i just i i guess it's also a bit
me like at some point i just got fed up
with the with the game
and i just had enough of it just like i
had enough of destiny about seven months
ago and then took a huge break from
destiny and then now i'm trying other
stuff for my youtube again
so it's like
it's just kind of just figuring out
whatever whatever i feel like i guess i
know it's very risky to do in a very bad
strategy on youtube
but i'd rather do that and then you know
i have this risky thing then just do the
same thing over and over and over again
until like i can't send it anymore
because if i can't enjoy making my own
videos then
i feel like it's gonna be hard for other
people to enjoy them as well i know
that's like objectively not true because
people do like the same type of videos
over and over again but as a creator
it's just not something that i can do
and still feel happy about
like at the end of the day i wanted to
do youtube because i thought making
videos was really cool and like you have
the freedom to do all these things and
be creative but if you're then gonna put
yourself into this one box this one
corner and never do anything creative
because you're too afraid it will fail
then like what was the point of getting
into youtube anyway in the first place
then i might as well just get like a
normal normal job
exactly because then you're just doing
the same thing again and again as well
so it's like respect
some things work some things don't
that's it and then
you'll figure it out among the way
hopefully
no it's like that's yeah i was going to
say a big respect for
taking the chance to be risky with your
content to switch from a game that
you know you have a lot of a following
for and switch over and you've got a big
enough audience you can kind of make a
shift and while you may not carry all of
them you're kind of in the same genre
and be like hey you guys should try this
and you know those videos have done
fairly well the one thing i wanted to
ask you is
time limited i could ask you a whole lot
more so it's like we're trying to
condense this intro but yeah yeah um
with regards to destiny like when you
come from division you've seen division
one have some good division two have
some bad some good some bad like i
remember in division one there was like
a currency and then all of a sudden the
streamers had a bunch of it and they
like made it really hard for everybody
certain things that you've watched
division
both see both the first one and the
sequel do is there anything with your
experience in destiny and believe me
we've actually talked about the new
player experience because i watched one
of your videos on those we all know
that's bad but are there things that you
see in destiny where
if they do this thing this could be bad
is there anything major that you see or
is there a worry that you have with
regards to destiny kind of lingering in
the back of your mind
i'm gonna be honest i feel like i'm just
not the right person to talk about that
because i honestly don't play the game
enough or have enough like super
in-depth knowledge about all the game
mechanics to really make an educated
guess there like i'd just be talking out
of my eyes back in the division i really
like knew the game so well inside out
with destiny that's just not the case
because i haven't cared to the same
extent
so
like i play destiny the right way friend
yeah i'm playing destiny to have fun and
then to make some content i really enjoy
destiny more than than a lot of destiny
mains because kind of the farther you
get into it the teddies of the world
teddy told me this week i was playing
with him and he was just like i found
out that i'm a lot happier when i
only play destiny as little as possible
just to get all the triumphs done and
then log off immediately and i was just
like that's so sad dude you used to love
this game and now that's your yeah so
well that was the situation i was in
with the division i feel like something
like that is just very hard to avoid if
you're forced to do it every single day
yeah there's no way developers can keep
up with that exactly so like that is not
even like a division or a destiny issue
that's just like that's just like
playing games 10 hours a day every day
and then
also your income being like weighted on
your performance and how like how much
you actually push it like there's no way
that's gonna keep entertaining
for anyone ever like that's i have the
biggest respect for people that grind
out these videos like every like week
after week after week after week it may
seem like
like you could call that oh that's just
not that creative or that's just a bit
lazy but in fact it's the other thing
it's like the opposite of lazy like
these people are really pushing
themselves to make sure that these make
it like that is
yeah so it's like
but that life is brutal i can't even
imagine that there are some people who
legitimately enjoy that lifestyle like
cogs friend uh dj oros that guy's a
seller but that but they're few and far
between
psychopaths i don't know if they
necessarily like enjoy it they're
probably just like they're very
dedicated is what you probably said oh
no you haven't met this guy man he is
he is on a next level he's never said a
bad word about bungie i think pete
parsons could walk into this dude's
bedroom every morning and wake him up by
stomping on his nut sack and he would
thank pete for the honor
and pay him 2 000 silver
that guy is absurd absurd
absurd okay
i was going to say real quick for with
your experience in division and then
coming over to destiny and you've got a
nice variety of games that it seems like
you've played
if you could bring one thing from
another game doesn't have to be division
but that's where most your experience is
what would you like to see in
development
like one or two top ones that you'd love
to see in division oh like those
loadouts for example would be very good
something like that did you know this is
some quality of life features uh would i
be able to pick up bounties from the map
and don't have to travel to the tower
every like that sort of stuff like why
can't i do that like just very basic
things they took that away yeah they
took it i don't know like all that's why
can't you like select stuff from them
and why they have to go to like a
hundred different menus just to get
somewhere to drill
all that stuff like that like i played
destiny i was like
what is this [ __ ]
i remember those early videos that's
what you were saying i remember you like
i don't think i'm gonna stay with this
long baby yeah this is it just doesn't
doesn't make any sense the only the only
redeeming factor is that the gameplay is
so good and the rates are still
exceptional and then you can look past
those things but like the menus and all
and the quality of life features the
vision did that a hundred times
the only better more annoying than
division mains coming and playing
destiny and like asking where all the
content is and all the the features are
people who come from wow and yes i am
talking to you ebontos
they're the most annoying because
they're like um well actually world of
warcraft was the progenitor for all of
these things
get get him real focused hey yeah
we gotta stay focused it's a big it's a
big show we got a lot of time so travis
was my question okay let's move on okay
let's do the news all right
we would sit here and ask you questions
for half the show and this could go on
for a while but we have so much stuff to
cover first thing that i do want to make
sure we absolutely talk about we can't
dwell a lot on but a lot of things keep
kind of trickling out about this and
that is the fact that sony bought bungie
they are now part of sony entertainment
interactive even though i feel like it's
part of sony pictures interactive but
that's a whole different piece we'll get
to in a second
it was for 3.6 billion uh we've actually
learned that 1.2 billion of this was for
employee retention um and we also know
that sony put out their couple
announcements from jim ryan and herman
holst but also we had pete parsons and
the destiny gentlemen both justin truman
and joe blackburn put out their post
with regards to division two or destiny
sorry that's the part of our guest
destiny 2 is going to stay
multi-platform through final shape
they've said that future releases aren't
going to
you know be published on any platform
they want to and you can you know read
some nuance into that one but this is
probably one of the biggest pieces of
news
at least in our little realm yesterday
was bigger because activision is just
massive and that's even being looked to
it by the ftc but i gotta go uh marco
first then we gotta get the other two
where are you guys without going into a
full-on like doctoral dissertation on
this thing with regards to sony and
bungie where are we at marco first like
does this news mean a lot to you is this
exciting scary where are you at um i i'm
pretty neutral on this uh i think a lot
of people blow out of proportion like
what what this is gonna do for the
franchise like obviously what they have
for which queen is already completely
locked in and i wouldn't be like
i i don't think there's gonna be much
changes for the next dlc even to come
uh i i the one thing that that's sort of
back in my mind is that maybe they'll
have access to more resources now so
maybe we'll get like a bigger dlc
two years later down the line but then
also
i mean it's not like like they have a
lot of money now but it's not like
they're going to have a lot more
talented developers instantly as a
result
so i don't think it's going to be the
same as when they had activision i just
don't i don't i don't really know
i feel like not much is gonna change
it's not really a bad or good thing uh
and i i just generally don't really care
too much about it
so i'll leave this for one one of you
two to dive into all right i'm gonna go
cog
um
look initial feeling a little nervous as
um uh xbox preferred mane of destiny so
you know it brought me back initially
when i first read the news across my
timeline because i was working it
brought me back to those dark days of
hawkmoon exclusive and
and you know jade rabbit and borealis
and maps and ex like it just took it i'm
like and then i read it and i'm like
wait a minute they are really stressing
multi-platform we control our own
destiny future platforms no platform
exclusives so when i started to see that
and then we had hogan um
defining duke and he really broke down
the language of the contract and what
bungie has done here is really
unprecedented for what as far as
negotiating independence and what they
can do they literally
unlike any other playstation studio with
the way things are done even on a
shareholder level that was the thing
that's brought because i push back at
hog i'm like wait a minute sony that i
know is used to exclusives and used to
having that hook to say yo you're gonna
you know this is and that is not the
case and and that that's the part that's
interesting so i'll wrap up in saying
that what i got out of it
is that sony's just two parts here sony
is looking to beef up their live
services and multiplayer deficiencies
and we'll have bungie help out with the
other studios with that and we're bungee
you got to be honest we already talked
about luke smith and mark noseworthy
being almost the kevin feige of the
situation right they look at destiny
movies tv they looking at that halo
infinite thing like paramount they want
this thing to go somewhere crazy
so at the end of the day we have to be
honest it is a good marriage in the
sense that sony can provide that so he
could be like oh you saw that that no
way home with tom holland you know like
we can do these kind of things so it's
early i think i agree with marco short
term nothing really initially is going
to change but long term i do think they
have stability and some resources that
can help them so surprisingly
it's a good fit you know i can't really
i know traffic is going to disagree but
i i i now that i've taken a step back
i think it's a good fit long term and
i've seen your face the whole time
yeah it's so bad
i'm gonna do a mini dissertation because
i could talk about this the entire year
this could be a whole show i know the
the more i think about it the more i'm
convinced that this is
the worst thing that's ever happened to
bungie and i and i i i really mean like
i'm i'm devastated by this news and it's
for i i really am i'm heartbroken this
whole week i've been just please
elaborate i'm really bummed about it um
so like i i'm one of those guys who
actually thinks that some consolidation
in the industry isn't that bad like i
wasn't bothered by the activision
consolidation even though it's a bigger
company and because i see the the
process of consolidation as being a
natural part of the games industry
companies grow and then they get big and
bloated and then when they start doing
poorly like activision was they were
getting attacked by the california
government at the top and they were
getting attacked in the bottom by their
own employees and you know blizzard
hasn't come out with a game since 2016
they were just getting squeezed right
and you can see their stock going down
and the fail state for that company like
that is that you get acquired it's like
you know it's it's that's the way our
system works it's you get acquired and
then you sort of get brought under
somebody else and and that's how you get
out right but i think that the it's a
travesty
that a company like bungie would get
acquired because they're not that type
of company they're an up-and-comer
they're what you call like a challenger
right they're this this new to me they
were the chosen ones they've always been
the chosen ones and i wanted to see them
grow up to replace a bethesda type
company these robust independent
companies that do third party stuff and
control their own destiny and
not no pun intended
and and and i honestly think that that's
what they that's what they've been
telling us for years that they were
going to do that's been all their
messaging is they want to do it they
they didn't work out with microsoft
they've gotten a really bad deal with
activision they've been saying that they
want to do this and their their
messaging on the fact that they're going
to be independent still from sony is so
disingenuous i it it's impossible like
their their contract for sure is set up
to do that but if you actually look at
what's happening
sony is getting 100 of their stock and
it'll it'll be fine in the in the short
term but in the long term sony's gonna
be making all the decisions and the
board members are gonna steadily be
replaced with people with sony's
interests
it is true it is true and and this is
actually something hogan and i have
talked about that they're they're at
home on our show it's literally i know
they cannot replace budgie's beard
holders they can't it's literally i'm
just saying i'm not saying they're going
to do it like a coup i'm just saying
naturally it's going to happen because
when sony controls your interests people
leave and then think piece by piece your
culture changes and that's going to
happen regardless of what they're saying
oh it i mean for the next five years
sure it'll it'll be fine and i honestly
think destiny is probably not a game
that will get that affected so if you
only care about destiny from bungie
you'll probably be fine but i care about
bungie as a company i've been i've been
invested in bungie for a long time and
i've seen them as like the this
up-and-comer challenger and now they're
not going to be that anymore now they're
getting absorbed by and by the way it's
not it's not playstation that bought
them it's sony interactive entertainment
and that means that they gave up this
vision they had and this position i
think they had as a as an as an
up-and-comer independent that could be
this challenger to challenge some of the
big companies they gave it up so for
what so they could drop a hot single on
sony music you know what i mean so they
can add movies and television like
that's not really what bungie's been
about they're they're game makers
is there a reason that you're so
invested into bungie and you want to
push this idealism in this industry for
them so much like where is this coming
from uh because you're saying it's not
it's not affecting destiny too as much
or will not as much yeah so like what is
the other motive for you to be so
invested in bungie i i mean i've i've
been playing bungee games long before
destiny and i'm sure i'll play them long
after and and i if for me they're
they are this
this tremendously talented company who
has always been defined by their
independence and they're willing to try
new things and they've been rebels and
so i just don't think this relationship
with sony is going to work the way
either part of it thinks
it's such a weird arrangement and i and
i get that they they probably set it up
in a way that's going to work in the
immediate future but but in in the long
term it's if them acting like oh
nothing's going to change our culture is
not going to change
it's [ __ ] there's there's no way you
get acquired by a large company with
interests that are completely different
than yours on the grand scheme of things
and that things don't change over time
that's just not going to happen and so i
think they're messaging that what if i
were doing if i were messaging it from
bungie i would have been i think a
little bit more transparent and saying
look our intention is for nothing to
change but of course it'll change stuff
and then talk a little bit about that
but they just acted like the acquisition
didn't happen like like playstation just
gets to put their logo on their games
and that's it and that's just not true
it's not true at all and that's what
hogan and i were talking about is just
like the fact that yeah this sort of
sort of agreement long term is there's
no way it won't actually think that's
where you meet that's what i mean yeah
so to me to answer your question marco i
just i think it's really important to
have these challengers in any industry
it happens in the tech industry too
which i'm also involved with is that
you've got the sales forces but then
you've also got these companies that are
challenging them and up and coming and
the worst thing that could happen to
celebrities
is for those challengers to get gobbled
up before they actually properly become
developed and and bungie to me is like
the best challenger because they've
always done things so much better and
punched above their weight and been that
company and now that's not going to
happen and then well that's partly true
like
bungie has punched above their weight
and has made some great games in the
past like it is also worth noting that
many of the original bunch of developers
that worked on like halo combat involved
in halo 2 they don't really they don't
necessarily still work at bungie like 15
years 20 years
100 but bungie has done a great job of
curating i think developers that are
sort of
are sort of more experimental and like
willing to try new things and i think
that's part of their culture and i i
think playstation benefits a lot from
this for me like i have no like question
why this happened i could because they
the to ibontas point when he was talking
about the contract you know 1.2 billion
or something like that of the
acquisition is going toward retaining
employees and i think they that's what
they want to me this is an accu hire
they're not they're accu hiring the
company they're not acquiring it you
know they want to keep the people and
that makes sense to me but i don't think
it's going to benefit bungie i think
it's going to benefit playstation
because all they have to do is stay at
playstation or sony to keep that that
benefit right and i think sony's going
to brain drain bungie and add people to
all these other ambitious live server
purpose projects that they want to work
on and it's going to make it bungee a a
less potent company they're i i just i i
i really bungee's like my favorite
developer ever like i have friends at
bungie i've been to their
headquarters like 100 times i love this
publisher or them as a developer and i
love the fact that they were
starting to be a publisher and starting
to get into it and it just feels like
their journey got cut off way before it
should and of course i'm disappointed at
that like they're they're now part of a
big corporation that's super well
established and that's way less exciting
and it changes their role in the
industry um and and i'm and i'm
heartbroken so i i don't blame people at
all for for feeling differently i don't
think that bungie's like an [ __ ] i
don't think that sony is evil any of
that stuff i'm just personally
disappointed that this is the path this
is this is what happened that happened
at this stage in their development and i
really want there to be challengers and
i'm looking forward to the people who
you know say no to the 1.2 billion quit
and start their own company that's sort
of like yeah
i think it will i think it will it
always happens it always happens because
and i think that's an important part of
the industry too is that when people
leave and they start their own thing i
think that'll happen it they'll they'll
be former bungee employees just like you
always hear former ea employees former
mass effect ads start their own company
like that sort of stuff happens also
yeah but then once they get handed like
a 1.2 billion back for themselves i
think i think they're also gonna and it
is a company called tencent that
people's taking bags from that they know
they should be taking yeah but you think
you think that individual people are
getting any significant amount of that
1.2 billion right away it's like a
monthly stipend you know i mean when you
look at it and
you know you know what i mean like it's
probably set up as like a long term
bonus that's what i think is that now
that sony has acquired bungie it is in
sony's best interest that bungie keeps
making the best possible games uh
because
that means their stock will go up so
that means that
like whatever power they have i i like
on whatever actions they can take or
willing to take i don't think it's ever
uh meant to put destiny or bungie or any
of the developing games no worse than
they would have thought without them i i
hope that's not that's not what i sound
like i'm saying i i don't mean that at
all i actually think that that a lot of
a lot of good things are going to come
of this obviously for bungie i just
think that they're probably not
solely focused on games i mean that's
why they sold the sony interactive
they're going to be focusing on movies
and tv shows and frankly stuff i don't
care about
because that's
zero confidence in sony's ability to
make a good movie just based on their
history so
from what i know the storytelling is
pretty bad but
you can't really say that that's like
not something that's not important
because like on one side we have mr bife
is here you know over here with a
million youtube channel
it's super important but like we've
talked about this on the last word
before about the the story thing and i
think the problem is that you can't
really make
i don't think tvs and movies if your
base
the story isn't good because then there
there's a cognitive dissonance between
the game and your other content and
and it's it's hard to manage a franchise
that way so like if if destiny was a
game that was like known for having a
great story and everybody was like oh
yeah you played destiny for the story
and then they made a movie or tv show
that would make sense but they're kind
of like trying to do it the opposite way
where they're trying to make the story
and destiny good by telling it through
other mediums and then keeping it sort
of
how do you think something first like
that we're gonna look like
okay
go ahead
go ahead like i i i would definitely not
be interested in like a movie with like
a savalas the main character because i
just don't care right but
i mean sure but i just don't i'm just
not too interested in the character that
he plays right like another story that's
currently developing in destiny 2 but do
you think like this whole universe that
they've built up over the years could
not make for decent sources
that's kind of what i wanted to break
into yeah i just don't think it will
because i just don't think it's really
good yeah i was like and that's kind of
thing you see people like mylon and biff
who have made these things bife is
working on his dynasty project off to
the side
book of sorrows there's a lot of cool
stories in this world and if they take
some of them or it's the battle on six
fronts you could do like a mini animated
show there's a lot of stories that i
think they could do
i think a big
motion picture at a theater box office
you would have to build up an audience
to that like you would have to
have either destiny come out with like a
destiny 3 if that's even like an or
whatever comes after the light and dark
saga
animated shows to really you'd have to
build some foundation i think before you
get into
a motion picture from sony because
that's a big investment and box off is
not cheap and especially if you're going
to do destiny there's going to be a lot
of cg this is not going to be a cheap
film but that is something i think they
do have the foundation and the stories
to tell
because the things that they've done
with their writers and when you sit
there and you have a four hour video
from buy for the history of this thing
there's a lot in this world that they
can do and this is not the only ip that
they're working on
so for me like i know you're very down
on this per se of what it could do to
the world of bungie what their up and
coming could do but for me on the other
side is we've seen bungie stumble bungie
is not perfect we've seen them stumble
plenty and this is where for me i see
the
yes things can happen in the future i
totally get that you could see like the
culture change there's i've never seen
the statements and then from what you
said cognito about the contract being so
unique i've never seen a deal come out
and be like they're going to be
independent they still have control over
their first bullet point like that's
like the most important thing i'm like
all these acquisitions we've seen i've
never seen it like that and yes things
can change they say future games will be
you know multi-platform do we know if
the future ip four or five years from
now is going to be on xbox no we don't
know that and things could change but
all i'm saying is
bungie is at a point where they do want
to expand
mark noseworthy and luke smith are above
the destiny game at this point because
they're trying to do more sony as you
said cog i think is one of the perfect
partners that they could do because they
do have a pictures division if sony is
in control of their ip people question
some of luke smith decisions so
if there's a little balance in there
we'll have to see but to me i see this
as sony possibly helping support bungie
and what they're trying to do and bungie
support sony in what they're trying to
do to me i see it as a general mutual
beneficial partnership
and then now if sony like wants to do a
live service game they can talk to this
company that's been through a whole lot
of mistakes they're still not perfect at
it by the way because we've seen
transmog and other things but if they
want to do a live service game i don't
imagine they're going to be all looter
shooters but they talked about gran
turismo 7.
they're like we're going to be adding
content in the future is this going to
be like their life they said 10 live
service they're not all live live like
looter shooters this is going to be
supporting games on a continuous basis
and i think seeing how bungie is the
only one who survived we've watched
division we've watched anthem fall
division had more of a life but yeah
like the employer attention seems like
unreal as that's one-third of the deal
you've got the independence and the
creative the creative independence and
also
their choice
again
but like these are the things i can only
worry so much it is a publisher it could
be five years away when these changes
happen and yes bungie is in an
up-and-coming state but also
they need help
sometimes they do need help and it's
like for them to complain about
resources for so long yeah and things
been neglected for so long as this
independent darling company that can't
sustain the damage they that they took
us two or three years how long does it
take to take it apart
but there's other ways to do it [ __ ] and
they've they've raised money in the past
they've proven they cannot sustain
this game in a way that the player bases
appetite could be satiated it's been
proven we've said they have talked about
trials for like four or five episodes
and and all these things gambit hasn't
even been touched they it's literally
the evidence is in front of us that they
cannot do it long term now to your point
though i do agree with you
what happens in the future we don't know
we don't this could go left i i'm with
you there this could be going live right
here
is
you can be worried about something in
the future but the fact that bungie is a
developer i think that is now they have
some security if they want to make a
leap with this you know they put a big
bet into this new ip we know what's
being worked on and they put a new bet
and as an independent publisher if all
of a sudden this new ip
tanks we've seen hyperscape we've seen
you know certain games do well certain
games tank depending on something like
them it's going to be a bigger risk and
if that risk happens what does that do
to our franchise that does make them
money does that push more into eververse
does that do things in a bad way and
then potentially if sony's out there as
at least a backbone to them they have
some support to either be a little
riskier or make some changes and just
overall
i know you like you have the personal
attachment to them and i've believed me
have eight years in this said while
mine's not as deep into halo it's like
that's one of the first shooters that i
played as well
they've done some good things and i
think
while we we don't know the future and i
think worrying about what could happen
five years down the road to this
you know publisher and game developer
that we really love
i don't know if it's worth putting so
much into that right now because we just
don't know
i'm not that's that's really a minor
part of what i'm worried about to cogs
point like but that sounds like the
major part of your time we've never
really succeeded at
fulfilling the demand for destiny that
we have but i see them selling to sony
as them giving up right them saying okay
we we give up on the idea of an
independent bungee we'll never be able
to fulfill this dream and i was sort of
on the team of like rooting for them
they're going to get there eventually
it's going to be a rough road but people
like you me and cog who do the show
every week and play and support them
we're gonna get them there because we
believe in this game and the studio and
i just think you know things are going
to change for the culture and the
company and the the idea just the whole
idea of them being a challenger that was
moving up and had full ability to do
their own thing is now gone and now
they're part of this big organization
and and that's happening now that has
nothing to do with what's going on in
the future right now
the bungie that i think they envisioned
that they sold to us the dream of that
independence is gone right away and that
makes me sad that's all i'm saying and
that's that's valid all i will say is
this it's like we know this company
right and
they're this prickly bunch
they kind of beat to their own jump they
do their own thing and i get that i know
the sentiment you have i was like wait a
minute this kind of what i first had to
do is like this kind of goes against
your whole mantra of independence in
this that's a beta switch yeah right but
one thing i know about bungie
they have learned through leaving
microsoft they learned they didn't
control ownership of an ip right halo
was not theirs left activision oh
forsaken underperformed right they
learned that as far as the control and
the release cadence of try to push a
sequel and then you know how activision
was with that churning out and remember
we got rise of iron when i was supposed
to be destiny too right so at the end of
the day they've learned then like yo no
one's going to control our cadence and
release cycle what i think with this
right and the way this is just my guess
and again we don't know the future is
that the way this contract is set up
if it goes left and let's say eventually
sony's tendrils come in and say hey we
need you to do blah blah blah and we're
gonna be doing this i feel especially
after the activity situation that
contractually they have set themselves
up to break
if they if they feel their terms are
violated because if that's the first
bullet point in this deal that they want
to promote somebody's promoting hey
they're independent i've never seen this
before so to me that shows how important
it is and if there's any type of
violation there based on my past
experience and my opinion again i'm
guessing they will break north again and
do what they do but
you know it remains to be seen we have
to see how this yeah yeah yeah yeah i
agree and then to your point like either
either this contract is set up because
they've learned from their mistakes in
the past or they haven't learned at all
and that they shouldn't be doing this
and it's going to backfire but and just
to be clear i i have nothing against
sony i i mean i don't know i don't know
particularly
but any if anyone acquired the microsoft
i would have been pissed if if you know
another third-party developer bought
them i'd probably be pissed like ea
buying them i'd be like
that you know like no way so
yeah i just i i wanted them to be
independent and i'm sad but but i i if
if the game became
playstation exclusive tomorrow
i'd turn on my ps5 and that'd be my
platform like i don't care
i deal with the with the bad uh joystick
players placement
well before we i was gonna say it's like
as we kind of wrap this thing up
there's a lot of information that
trickles out there can be some fears
about the future it is a very unique
deal to say the least and i am very
curious to see
what happens with sony if they get like
the support if bungie you see changes
from them of either more or less or
support studios when you say developed
by bungie and hey we had this help from
this other sony team that helped us get
this expansion who knows but it does
seem very unique and i think we've all
got different perspectives and i see
even chad is kind of all over the place
like is it good
so it's like i think everybody has a lot
of up in the air but i think the unique
nature of this deal is something that we
all will keep our eyes on very closely
and as you guys have said if the
language is there if bungie has learned
if it's not beneficial to both parties
they can potentially have a chance to
break this thing apart but again it's
like there are there is potential
i can see the fear of what could go
poorly but also on the other side i can
see the potential of where these two
companies can actually synergistically
help each other a lot and i think that
is something for the future because even
you being xbox like this is multiplayer
this is like xbox they're like this is
their multiplayer single player just
just one hashtag just one game it's like
and now you've got something that is
happening
yeah i was like now you've got sony
who's like the
multiplayer single player guy and then
you like making amazing motion cap like
what if they got to use like naughty
dog's motion capture studio for just
there's certain things where you and
again does that happen i have no idea
but
i think there's chances for good things
and there's oh there are legitimate
things to fear i just think at this
point there's it's one of the more
unique deals in the world of
acquisitions and i'm just very curious
to see where it goes
what if sony and bungie uh make the next
arcane you know
oh yeah but if that comes out of that
it's like i would i would watch i mean i
i would hope arcane would be a
independent studio that could i just i
don't have that much uh the confidence
in the ability of large corporations to
create like
young like uh you know i think we're
talking about a different arcane there
because i was talking about the tv show
that came out yep
that's that's actually i for me it's not
about future fear it's about the stuff
that already has happened that makes me
sad about like the fact that you know
the whole independent bungee dream is
basically over or at least for the
foreseeable future unless something goes
terribly wrong but the way i see it e
sony benefits a ton it's probably going
to transform their business because they
want to focus on live service games and
bungie is the studio too
i get it for them i just feel like we
traded they're getting that and what is
bungie getting in return
music tv shows movies it reminds me of
the time xbox got on stage and was like
tv tv sports and we were like what the
this isn't what any of us want and so
that's that's my concern it's like okay
so they're getting movies
that may not be something that you want
but that's something bungie seems to
want they want they they've shown i was
like
why but again this is like
microsoft also wanted to be a tv box
that didn't make it good it didn't make
it a good idea you know what i'm trying
to do it's not necessarily a bad thing
because like if you look at for example
a game like the witcher everybody loved
that and then they started making the tv
show the netflix show and that was a
huge success many people wasn't as good
as the video game so yeah but you can't
you can't take away trash you can't take
away from the witcher right now netflix
is popping it's powerful i 100 agree but
if but if but if uh the the studio cd
projekt red announced that they're gonna
spend 50 percent of their time making tv
shows
split focus and their their ambition is
sort of like their their eyes are bigger
than their stomach in this case i think
they should make their game amazing and
i think they have a lot of work to do
there and they're they're over here
playing with tv and movies
what if that sony bag let them hire they
like you know what i'm saying it's a big
you know 3.6 billion they're all
billionaires
it takes completely different talent to
take a tv show than to actually work on
a game like those things cannot be done
by the same people
at all so like if if they're going to go
to brutal tv show and all that stuff um
they're probably just gonna sit around
the table with some of the the writers
but the people that are gonna be doing
that is is nobody that currently works
at bunch
of different people it would be
different people but they're fighting
over the same budget and if you put your
money into developing an arm for tv
development that's money that's not
going into developing the game that is
true all right and so now they're going
to have this tv studio arm they're
spreading their money out and i just got
a whole bunch of games
i don't think that
the reason that bungie or like the
destiny 2 is not good in some areas it's
not a money problem
it wasn't i don't think it was they have
so much money and they like they could
they couldn't spend it all to make their
games
they're talking constantly about needing
more support and needing more employees
and all that stuff and so now they've
got the money and what are they doing
with the money they're making tv shows
yeah is
okay
marco's got a valid point so it's like
i'm trying to let him get his in
but basically what he's saying is like
they just got 3.6 billion 1.2 to keep
people on but that also doesn't mean
they just said hey we're hiring a butt
ton more people they've said this on
like the sony post and everything so
it's not like
as you're saying the money for the game
division mark was saying is like you
have a completely different team you see
people hired for tv film music and
comics like that is going to be a
different division of bungie so the
amount of money same money no no it's
not even going to be it could not even
be a division of bungie like what if
sony now owns bungie and therefore can
do stuff with ip and then sony just pays
for the tv show yeah and so like they
have way deeper pockets they have way
more resources they have the studio the
bungie just has to get the writers
around the table once in a while kind of
directed in a similar manner everything
could be done by sony without affecting
the focus of bungie whatsoever
i just i don't think that that's what's
going to happen because basically
however that is pretty much said in
their post that they this is what they
want out of it is they want to be able
to expand the universe yeah but
now now that sony and bungie are the
same organization they are sharing the
same pool of money whether you like it
or not and i just think that the focus
now i it's just not to me if you're if
you were going to grow the business and
raise a bunch of money it should be
focused on the main thing that you were
doing it's like you ever been into one
of those places that serves like mexican
food and fried chicken and you're kind
of like i don't know about this i feel
like you guys are doing a little too
much it's like a kfc taco bell it's
never going to be as good as the full
just taco bell you know what i mean like
now they're doing all this different
stuff and that's except sony already has
i'm disappointed so he already has the
studio so he already has the stuff
working on that they're not trying to
reinvent the wheel or trying to correct
like mcdonald's is not trying to become
a burger king if i were to take your
example you have some of the some
company that owns like a lot of the
high-class restaurants like that that
has a really high class restaurant with
a burger and someone somewhere you can
get really high-class fries and now they
bought something where you can get some
good salmon doesn't mean that the salmon
place is certainly going to also serve
fries and do it worse than what they're
like they have the movie studio already
they have to talent there and yeah
they just have to communicate
i totally agree i totally agree i just
think that if but if this was a move by
bungie to do a specific thing they said
right there in plain english what their
reasoning was right and it had nothing
to do they want to expand the universe
and they don't have a feeling they had
nothing to do with the game so they sold
their company so that they could expand
not in game so they could not improve
the game in fact all the messaging was
nothing about the game's gonna change i
want things to change but okay like
this is the last thing we have to move
on
take forever
but the one thing we're gonna say is
you don't know it won't change just
because that's 3.6 billion i don't know
1.2 billion for employees but you don't
know that that money isn't going to the
game and just as marco perfectly phrased
it sony has sony pictures they have an
entire company for making films and
making these other things and if they're
like okay so any pictures we're going to
make a division movie let's consult over
here on the writing the lore get the
story straight and then they go make a
movie
that's what you like that potentially
helps 2.4 billion outside of employer
attention coming to sony to help make
the game that you are so frightened and
worried about and turn around sony can
go over there and make a movie with the
lore of the ip and everything else if
they buy an ip and they make a movie and
bungie has now a lot more money support
other studios from sony studios to make
a game you have potential that's all i'm
saying is every time somebody gives you
an option you're saying no it's not
going to do that no it's not the
potential is there is all i'm saying
okay so they also close off a lot of
options by getting acquired by a company
like sonny they're no longer independent
they don't control their own destiny
there's all these other doors that are
closed
that i care about the one thing that
they state is that they actually control
their creative independence and that's
been plastered everywhere the first time
and it's like and if you say that it
shows the level of importance to them
sorry yeah and i'm just gonna control
our independence and we're getting
acquired so we can make movies right and
you you projected it yeah like that's
for sure that's what they said that's
what they said they said this is a move
today they said they're using it they
said they're going to stop making games
stop improving yeah
if you're going to get acquired
shouldn't the reason that you get
acquired the main reason so that you can
improve your video game wouldn't that be
what you want to say
at the same time i understand why one
has to stop why are we projecting
negative energy this is their own
messaging cog this is their own message
we gotta stop we remain independent and
we're not gonna change our game we just
sold our company to make movies that is
we'll talk about this in the future we
just do not have time
anyway
so as you can tell there are definitely
opinions about that chat is somewhat
divided we have opinions but we gotta
move on there's this game that they're
developing and putting money into and we
have a future in this thing called the
witch queen we actually got a lot of
information about it this week to say
the very least
so
uh first thing that came was the actual
exotics trailer that was like the first
little piece of information we got uh
exotics we got the grand overture a slug
launcher that charges a full auto
missile launcher we got the parasite
worm launcher with increasing damage
ostio striga
that one's gonna have swarming
projectiles that trigger a toxic burst
we have the three different glaives the
titan one makes a shield warlock makes a
healing turret the hunter makes the
chain lightning waveform across the
ground you got a titan exotic that does
a giant stasis wall that thing's huge
the osmeomancy which is the double cold
snap enhanced tracking grenades
and the blight ranger uh you've got
reflected projectiles deal increased
damage that's with the arc staff
reflection super from this trailer like
this is kind of the first thing that
dropped this week was the trailer before
we even got to an article what exotics
excite you the most from what you guys
have seen
and marco guests usually get honors i i
go first okay so um
i don't i don't really have a particular
exotic that i was like wow i'm so
excited for that but i do like that
there's
ah they're going more and more in the
direction of having so many different
type of weapons that do something unique
and and and that's what i really like
that's uh like i almost have to compare
to
the wretched and clank games where every
weapon you get is so unique and so
different from another and has such such
a unique thing to the gameplay and uh i
mean that is
like we've all seen the another 140 hand
getting another 150 hand cannon or
whatever you have 180 hand cannons now
uh so so having more of those is
definitely fun but i mean there's i'm
not really the loot type of guy i don't
really go for got roll so as long as
it's like fun to use a couple times like
that that will be it for me
shout out to sir america it's a 2000
super chat yeah there's two dollars you
guys now go kiss yes
i've told paul to his face that i hate
his guts and i'm just kidding
but we we we love each other we talk
about this stuff because we love bungie
and we love passionate exactly it's not
fashion it's passion we feel like if you
let them have a little faith in them
anyway exactly no one was against this
move wouldn't it be weird to have a
panel for people who were all like oh
yeah this is the best thing ever there's
got to be some guy we're done with this
anyways continue dog exotics what
excites you sir the warlock one with the
with the rift i'm all about that i'm all
about riff action and then getting up
the road recovery i already think about
builds in my mind i'm ready to go but
check out what you got track healing
yeah i i also like the glaive i like
that both the titan and the warlock
glaive are designed specifically to keep
warlock players alive
yo
because you can heal yourself with your
glaive and then i can shoot a bubble at
you to protect you because you don't
know how to play the game because you're
a warlock
i like the i like the titan glaive i
think that's my favorite new exotic
lucky lucky walk over here and tell you
that yeah
i can't talk slanderous because i like
you guys
i'm jumping right now i'm just going to
pull my book out shut up
you're just going to flip your way down
to the bottom
uh for me honestly it's that first one
the i mean the titan glaive is cool for
the projection the glaive i'm wondering
how for the specific exotic glaives if
we're going to like build up a charge
because it's like if you can run into a
pvp match with a glaive
and every death be able to shoot that
launcher out that seems a little op or
the healing turret so i wonder is it
going to be like some type of build up a
charge by blocking or stabbing to be
able to get that projectile i'm kind of
curious the functionality of how the
exotics work but the one that got me is
just the first one in the trailer
the slug launcher that you seem to
charge this like electric it seems like
an arc
xenophage is how it seems to fire is
like that big shot and then you see him
ads just this wave of a missile barrage
that seems to wipe out everything in
front of them so honestly that one just
seems unique for a heavy exotic because
it seems like if it's slug you can have
some range and control but if you need
to wipe a room all of a sudden now you
can it actually seems like it's got a
lot of potential both sides and of
course
nobody's going to talk about launching a
worm we have a worm gun
that was cool that was cool now that's
right
that's like the big thing i remember
from that trailer because i scanned
through it like when it came out a
couple days ago and that's like the one
thing i remember aside from having uh
like a bubble
uh coming out of your clave as well yeah
like those were the two highlights yeah
the only thing is all i can say is this
better be a functional exotic and we
better not get another salvations grip
story exotic that's all if it's a
function this is going to be a one thing
to do and then it's never going to be
used again that's that's that's pretty
sure that's my worry you fire a worm in
like three places and you put the thing
in your vault never touch it again so
exactly it's not that that's like eighty
percent of the weapons though and that's
pretty much that's not wrong
you're not wrong um
so that's most of the exotics uh very
excited to see and we know there's more
because there's a helm for
the titans that looks like it's on fire
we don't know what that one's going to
be there's shoulders for
uh the hunter
and there's some we don't even know yet
so those are just like pictures in a
trailer
the flaming thing is is obviously for
bungie employees like what they did with
halo reaching halo 3 back in the day
right the flaming helmet you don't know
that
oh yeah yeah i was going to have
absolutely
i think that's also infinite right now
in a battle pass but it's not as
exclusive exclusive you know
yeah yeah
it's gonna buy five bucks for it and
that's it
speaking of five dollars super chats
really oh okay yeah okay yeah it's a
part of the season pass gaming forte
with the five dollar stupid chat
everyone knows cog was going to pick the
warlock exotic of course that man would
pick that option even if it wasn't a
choice
i would go an hour defending warlocks
but we got three titans we got long
shows so i can't do my normal slander
back out yeah that's fine trust me i'm
keeping it in i'm bottling it up okay uh
the next thing we got was a game
informer article which actually went
into a decent amount of information with
regards to
a little bit of weapon crafting we're
going to get into more of that once we
get to the actual twab but the big thing
we got was a little information about
the campaign and they're calling this
the definitive destiny campaign after
playing taking king after playing
forsaken those are strong words they're
saying you've got player quantity
scaling so if you go in at higher
difficulties they're actually going to
scale the missions with multiple players
i think that's the first time they've
ever mentioned anything like everything
is just the same all the time
but the fact that they've got player
scaling legend difficulty they really
are harping on that replayability of the
campaign the rewards for going back to
play it um is in it sounds like this is
savathun's this is sabathoom's ultimate
story
and i know we've talked about the
campaign before marco i don't know how
in like into the story you are for it
are you excited for savithoon or the i
know okay
all i know about the story pretty much
that's uh that's what i remember from it
i remember
that
i actually cared so little about the
story up until this point that i usually
play with the dialogue disabled so even
when i'm doing all the seasonal
activities yeah let's make a movie out
of this i have to stand next to the
characters and sit there for a couple
minutes uh without them actually
speaking to each other so i don't
actually know what's going on uh all too
much i'm just more interested to see
what they do with the gameplay here uh
see how they change it up obviously
weapons aside we have all these enemies
now that actually have abilities i think
like light abilities and all that stuff
and and so i'm hoping that will change
up the gameplay in a major way
and also do like a lot of stuff to the
rate
uh that will that will give us some
interesting mechanics to play around
with there that's mostly what i'm
looking forward to
uh other than that not really 2d printed
the story
that's fair
that's the fact the fact that they are
putting uh
the whole campaign like putting it as
replayable and putting a higher
difficulty in there that leads me to
believe it's more than just the same old
bad guys we've been shooting over and
over and there's going to be a little
more to it hopefully
travis
um i just hope the uh in addition to the
because i'm a little worried about them
saying that the uh
the game gets more difficult when you
add people i do want it to be more
difficult when you add people but i
don't want it to be like night
grandmaster nightfalls where they're
just like beefy for no reason i would
what i would like is for them to add
higher enemy density at scaling like
just more people because that's always
been a problem when you play a campaign
in co-op is that there's some people
that just have nothing to shoot at you
know so i would like that uh as a as a
preference for if they're going to scale
the difficulty
yeah good point um i agree on the enemy
density part i do like the care because
i was one of those guys that really
liked the red war campaign and it kind
of bummed me out when d2 launched and
then it was like you can't go back first
of all it's the content in the game
right now it's in the vault that's
another thing that's another story but
look i like the fact that they're taking
it seriously there's gonna be difficulty
scaling to me it shows that they are
really putting the effort in and i'm
with marco in the sense that
i really in order for this to live up to
the mythical title as far as campaign we
would agree taken king is probably up
there what we what i would need is for
this to transition beautifully into the
raid and that to me is always key when
you have that narrative connection
that's what made me fall in love with
take a kick and then you go right into
the raid
i mean you beat the campaign you think
oryx is beating nope we got to go to the
strong world okay boom you go into
thermal it's an amazing difficult
hardcore raid and then even after the
raid it's the remnants of the taken war
the map changes everything so i want
that metamorphosis and also kind of like
what forsaken did where you don't we
thought it was just tangled shore boom
talisman and now you got this beautiful
locale right the dreaming city like if
they transition this thing seamlessly
they got potential so that's what i'm
hoping for and then they also opened the
dungeon uh for the for the forsaken
campaign after beating the last wish
right like they had like another thing
coming and another thing yes and the
cycle of the storm like forsaken is is
highly rated just for those type of
transitions
narratively yeah my word my worry is it
won't quite go forsaken especially
because again the supports are getting
not going to pan out for a little while
to like make this expansion better but
i know they've told us like raid dungeon
raid dungeon in future seasons so i feel
we're not going to get that sabbath
unlock the um shatter throne unlock
moment but i'm 100 with you that if
the story has got a tie to the raid
if we just go deal with sabathune in a
throne world and whether we face her
whether we have a discussion she's
hopefully a year-long thing if we kill
her in a story mission you know i'm
going to be pissed
but if there is a discussion as to we go
to the throne world we have the
interactions with sabathun whatever
happens there
some tie in to go into that pyramid ship
that is on her throne world that is this
reflection of her mind i need a reason
to go there if it's just like here's the
raid going to this ship we need a reason
why
that's the biggest one and we did get
confirmation
for the lucent brood you will have to
finish their hive ghost off they
actually said that you are gonna have to
finish them or they'll respawn in a few
seconds just kind of like we do
so it's actually one of those you'll
have to finish them off with your hand
though my problem is basically yeah
you could shoot it that would be great
they said
you have to use uh paracausal bullets
and all that so i i just don't know so
they well they said you have to be close
enough to do a finisher so they really
want you to close that gap and i think
part of the reason we're getting a
glaive is due to the multifunction
nature of a shield you have a way to
push in try and get that shield off you
might have to thin the herd but you have
that shield potentially from your glaive
to push in and go for that so
they did say you are going to have to
get up close and personal i think to
finish these things off so you are going
to have to no more sitting in the back
planking off stuff
you're going to have to get in the mix
big grand master i know believe me i
know bro
can you imagine uh soloing something
that's terrifying i'll watch that
first that's fine i'm wondering like i
do you think that these these new enemy
types will be in strikes and stuff
that's the questions
because
i think they will because they also
retroactively put all the the champions
in all their raids or other strikes and
stuff like that wasn't the thing until a
certain update and now they're in every
single strike every single grandmaster
right yeah so all these enemies
aren't i think the rate is
the rate is supposed to be scorned isn't
it or we don't know what we've seen oh i
i don't know i misspoke when i set rate
but i'm definitely thinking like all the
strikes all the the dungeons or whatever
like we might see these type of enemies
appear because the same happens for the
for the champions barrier champions
unstoppables all that stuff i can see
that being annoying having to finish off
everyone in person where they come back
i can see that being annoying and again
well there might be some other mechanics
and some some mods and some other stuff
that lets you do it from range right
yeah
for me to shoot those uh shoot those
ghosts for a distance i'm sure they'll
have solutions right like yeah yeah do
so we'll see but it does present a
challenge i i understand what travis is
talking about is hard content
so i think uh i don't think there's too
much else in there they did talk about
weapon crafting working into that here
in a second they give a little bit on
the glaive itself just a little detail
of how it's gonna work it's their first
first person melee weapon
for the melee itself you can have a
combination kind of like this maybe two
three four hit combo of jabs that you
can actually stab them with it's gonna
have a short to range short to medium
range
energy blast projectile of some kind and
again this is how i wonder if you have
to charge that up or if the exotic
functionality maybe it's a hold reload
and you charge the shield into it
still got to know the functionality
there but you also have the defensive
shield so it is this jack of all trades
but the combo of jab melee i can't wait
to see the animations on this first
person melee spear that we've got in
this game because while bows are like
unique for destiny i still can't figure
out if this is gonna feel good or not i
just can't wait to get my hands on it
i'm sure it will because they do well
with all their weapons but it's just
it's one i gotta get in my hands because
it has me
it could feel very like
it could feel really stupid
but it also could be cool if they do it
right so i'm just very curious oh
they've made the energy sword than the
gravity hammers before so i'm sure
they'll nail this as well it's not
exactly the same but it's kind of in the
same ballpark right yeah my worry is
that they're marco to your point is
obviously they can do melee weapons well
but because this one is melee in range
it could end up being too
too middling too weak at either of those
because they can't make it amazing at
both right otherwise everyone would just
use glaive so i think i think you can
get it right a little bit i think you
can get away with making it about as
good as a normal primary weapon because
the melee ability you'd have to get up
close anyway so for high level and hard
content it's not always viable plus
you're probably stuck in an animation as
well
so
it i could see it being strong either
way uh yeah but you know uh well i don't
know if you play pvp but you if you do
then you know the uh the history of of
bungie with uh with melee animation
canceling
so i could see that and i don't know the
shoot melee cancel that they do that the
bx aring and halo
you can push them off a ledge if you
just reload and put in like melee the
whole time and in halo 3 as well
yeah i worry about that like if it's a
if it's an animation can you like shoot
and then immediately melee and and start
making something already built so yeah
he ate his pvp
we're going against the cheetah
i'm
could be really dangerous for pvp six
months in advance and then it just
destroyed the game for
pvp very many non-dark times for pvp
i haven't really like at this point i'm
like yeah anything that comes out is
just going to break it and i've just
stopped caring to be honest that's a
good that's a good mentality to have
just accept what happens and
roll with the fact that not taking this
thing too seriously
but
but the big information we got was the
6 000 word twab of all the craziness
now i'm going to try and cover some of
the high points with regards to some of
these chunks and then kind of get your
appeals because i'm not going to read
this thing verbatim i've got a bit of an
outline so we're going to see so weapon
crafting is the first piece of it
and from what we've seen in weapon
crafting i think i've seen a general
positivity towards it with a little bit
of
you know trepidation with regards to
some of the longer term pieces of it but
the idea is with crafting everybody is
going to get the first missions of witch
queen number one and number two they're
free to all players and this is what's
going to introduce us to weapon crafting
you're going to be getting a pattern
which is kind of like a blueprint you
can picture that you're going to collect
materials to kind of build the base
weapon and then through combat you're
going to unlock the potential so it's
going to happen the first one you're
going to go through the first two
missions you're going to find the
enclave which is where all of this
weapon crafting is going to take place
really cool looking room
and you're actually going to be given
all the materials you'll find your first
piece and this is where you're going to
basically craft your first glaive
so the crafting is going to begin around
the glaive after that it's going to
unlock the other weapons
and the big things we've got is there's
going to be resources that you find out
in the world
there are also other resources that we
get ready that we are able to actually
um do objectives for depending on where
you find and a lot of this comes from
the deep site
basically ability that we're going to
acquire in these first two missions and
also the deep sight resonance weapons
that we're going to find we actually
have a new outline color on weapons
they're going to be red
so the deep site resonance is going to
have this objective and on a weapon and
they basically describe it as
take a high impact auto rifle that's got
rampage on it and you've got the deep
set resonance perk on it
use the weapon for a while whether it's
in activities or number of kills or
however you do it and then they describe
it as if rampage is on that weapon and
you complete the objective with the deep
sight resonance you're going to either
unlock and again we don't know if this
is a consumable or a one-time thing or
if it's just unlocked for good the
rampage perk now you can take that
rampage resonance in theory or they say
other damage perks back to
your crafting table and theoretically
now make your weapon with it and you can
either craft a new weapon or you can
reshape weapons so you can't actually
make different weapons as we go
uh there's a new currency we knew that
was going to happen travis sorry but so
far i've only seen one just one like
moving they're removing a few yeah we're
getting rid of that
so it's a good thing that's going to be
your resonance alloy whether it's with
regards to reshaping or crafting that
seems the main important piece
once your weapon is crafted and this is
the one where some people are worried
but also are kind of enjoying the
investment
um combat and activities is how you're
going to level up your weapon
so you're going to be able to take it
and enhance the stats and the traits and
unlock higher perks and be able to
switch even archetypes it looks like
from a high impact you're going to be
able to switch things around on these
weapons that really allows you to
customize it to make your own piece of
gear so that's the general overall
you've also got things like mementos uh
the first one is going to be a
gambit-themed one later on you're going
to have grand masters and trials they're
really going to push us into this new
gambit experience they are going to push
us there but that's going to have its
customized tracker but it's also going
to be a way to
change the appearance on the weapons so
some of these things which i do think
does open a lot foreververse which you
guys would imagine we talked about that
but i also think if you can't earn them
through grandmasters if you can earn
them two trials if you can earn them
through raids
having an option for both like hey is
this cool when you can buy or you go do
the raid you get it too the big balances
we're looking for both so before we get
into other things that's the main
rundown of weapon crafting just in kind
of a brief piece of it with regards to
even our division man over here marco
and you had weapon crafting changing out
perks and stuff like that i mean how
does this sound to you with regards to
you know destiny's not so much into
builds and then also there's a whole lot
of rng coming from a game of crafting
does this excite you actually to be able
to you know invest time is the time to
worry for you
i i don't think it's i don't know if
it's going to make me care
too much about the guns and destiny
still it might make me care a little bit
more because
getting towards some of the the roles on
like guns and
armor even
might be a little more accessible this
way i still don't think you'd be able to
just craft a straight up god roll i
think the way this is going to work you
can either craft a gun and then
like it's gonna come out pretty random
or like you can only select a couple of
things to have and then you can swap out
one thing but you still need to get
lucky and invest quite a lot to
uh to get the got roll because if you
were to just able to craft a god roll
that that completely like invalidates
the all other portions of the game and
the whole looting aspect that's actually
what happened with the division the
division one at some point like
we had a crafting station
where you would just craft one gun and
then it would come with random perks
um and then you could recalibrate one of
those perks right and then so you'd have
to get lucky to get two out of the three
perks right and then you can make the
god roar yourself
uh and and the problem was is that it
was really really easy to get materials
to craft a gun so instead of doing like
activities to farm for a specific thing
you'd end up just
farming boring materials and just
sitting at the crafting station like a
thousand times to just roll away until
you finally got the right gum that's uh
that's that's how that went i think yeah
um so i wonder how destiny is really
going to do this like how close will it
let you get to the to the god roll uh
and how much of that will invalidate
actually playing activities because at
the moment it becomes about materials
uh just like i mean you already know
what's gonna happen people are just
gonna speed run the one the one thing
that takes the shortest amount of time
by like 10 seconds and that's the only
thing people will ever play right and an
individual one that happened to be clear
sky
uh like an incursion that took like five
minutes and you got like a whole bunch
of [ __ ] for that
and in destiny it's gonna be like like
shadows
right like that's just the moment the
moment they make it too accessible like
it's just destiny just turns into lake
of shadows the game pretty much or like
whatever activity there is the game
uh so
i think crafting is cool
i think the the changing of perks can be
cool
but i highly doubt that's going to be an
efficient way to get your god rolls
because the moment they allow you to do
that
you don't have you only play like one
thing of the game and then that's all
how you get like all your loot pretty
much ever right whereas now you get a
whole bunch of different guns for doing
this and this and this and this and the
sword is all different so it forces you
to actually play the game in a somewhat
more more normal way right or like grind
out strikes one day and maybe go to the
crucible the other day you might not
like everything but it's still better
than just playing one thing over and
over and that's kind of like
that's kind of like what i think about
that
yeah
um i've been different i don't know how
to feel about this like there's a part
of me that's excited
that they're attempting it but then
the limits of
combinations of what you actually could
do part of me feel there's going to be
some restrictive data to marco's point
where it's like you know the minute that
there has to be checks and balances in
place
from from from their standpoint of
balance is that they're not going to
allow us to go completely crazy right so
i'm indifferent i just need to see
because
are these changes truly going to be
transformative in the game and i don't
want to sound negative but it's just
like i'm not sure you know what i'm
saying i'm not sure if this is something
that i'm going to be invest investing a
lot of time in and then i'll tell you
what because my main concern is my only
my main concern is
d1 is for as much as i love it and it's
beloved there was a point i think
somebody said it in chat where it was
like
you're farming specific materials and
activities because you know it's going
to give you this particular thing and i
understand the idea of living with your
gun and and remember filling out the
circles chad we used to fill out the
circles of the d1 and all that stuff but
i just applied it yeah the multilight so
i i just need to see
how this affects the day-to-day
experience with weapons how does this
truly change is it going to be something
that is positive all the way i'm not
trying to put out negative energy but i
just i need to see it before i can say
one thing one thing i'll say on it as
well like one last thing that i kind of
forgot to mention is that sure the way
that this could work really right
is to do it in a combination with the
system we have right now to where you
keep a lot of the guns
like uh
i don't know some some stasis auto rifle
or whatever like in trials is it another
right i don't know if it's not anyway
like they have a lot of very specific
guns that
are tied to their activities that still
forces players out to go to do those
activities and still forces them to
grind it and then you just have a
limited pool of guns you can craft like
there's only
like eight different guns you can craft
just like how there was a there was only
like eight war mined uh weapons for
example you have some rules in there
some guns seem interesting some some
stuff that you can really get a benefit
out of but it's not that you can just
craft every archetype in whatever way
you want like you can't just that would
that would be that would completely
defeat the purpose of everything they
have so far in destiny right now
mm-hmm
travis
what's that
on just weapon crafting on kind of the
hole
yeah um i
i'm i'm feeling pretty good about weapon
crafting
um it seems like they're like i i like
the way that they've set it up i like
the fact that you can make perks i i
think um to marco your point like you
can craft weapons but it doesn't seem
like you can craft the best weapons in
the game
just based on what they talked about
with trials and grandmaster nightfalls
having
still having the adept weapons with an
extra perk and being able to take mods
out of their weapons can't that's all
still remaining in place it sounds like
based on what they said really the only
part i'm concerned with is kind of what
cog was talking about with materials and
grinding and i i'm really worried about
the leveling up weapons part the fact
that you have to go out in the world and
fight with weapons that aren't completed
yet because we tried that in destiny 1
and it wasn't really good because
people really didn't like to have to go
out and use a mediocre gun for five
hours of gameplay just so that they
could use a good gun after that it was
just like not good and so what ended up
happening is people just grinded moats
of light and then would just burn all
the motes of light so that they didn't
have to do that part and i worry about
uh
that happening um again kind of
basically like them people people
complaining about the time it takes to
grind a gun up to where it could be full
potential and crafting and then bungie
going okay well here's a material that
lets you skip that part of the process
and then all of us thinking a year from
now why is this even a part of the
process everyone just skips it anyway
and then that whole conversation so i
could just see that happening but never
experienced that but yeah that would be
that would be pretty annoying terrible
yeah really annoying and then at that
point you're just like nobody actually
does it so why is this even in the game
everybody just skips it so um yeah i
could see that happening but honestly i
i'm i i was
much more uh optimistic about the weapon
crafting than i thought i'd be so i'm
pretty i'm pretty happy i am um a little
disappointed that my theory about them
adding uh
the uh 10 power onto weapons and you
being able to equip mods that whole
theory i had that theory and a few
others and it seems like based on what
they've told us so far that's probably
not the case so that's unfortunate but
yeah i mean for me i think i'm kind of
with travis as well i have a couple
things i got to see how they are in
action but i think generally this can be
positive because they talk about
pursuit weapons and i'm not really going
to touch on that because they just give
why they're there pursuit weapons work
is this thing that's like 70 of a god
roll you have a direct path at it
anybody can go for it it's not going to
be the be all and all perfect could be
the best thing ever but it is a way for
every player at every level to go get a
decent roll and i think this for the pay
there are players who truly log in and
go play strikes that is like their hey i
got an hour to play before i got to go
to bed the kid's already in bed i got an
hour i'm going to do a couple matches
whatever they use this weapon in combat
they're able to unlock it more and one
thing i did want to read verbatim
is they said once a weapon is crafted
guardians may begin to increase its
level by using it in activities and
defeating enemies we know that uh this
is where the bulk of your crafting play
time will begin the more you use weapon
the faster your you will unlock its full
potential enhanced stats and traits
which i'm going to get to traits in a
second because those are brand new can
be unlocked when reaching higher levels
granting slight bonuses to your weapons
and capabilities and you also can see
here there are different ones where you
pick a frame and it says he's going for
the high impact frame that says this
weapon will unlock a minor stat boost at
like level 20. we know they're getting
rid of most of the reason to masterwork
a weapon besides the minor stat bonuses
for they said literally said it's mostly
for pvp but now if you spend time with
the weapon it's not a currency it's a
time thing
where you can actually get some stats
out of it but maybe if the high impact
frame gets a little extra handling or
the rapid fire frame gets a little bit
more stability and they are truly
it looks like they're giving a few more
weapons identity which i do like to see
and then but again my worry is this
whole resonance currency that we've got
so you'll find a weapon it has the red
outline it has this like deep sight
resonance use this weapon and you'll go
through the atomic process and then
that's how you pull weapon perks out
i'm wondering if the weapon perks are
going to be consumable if you've just
unlocked it at the weapon table how much
of this deep sight resonance grinding
you've got to do all the time using
these just like okay weapons and
activities just to get this resonance
because you've got one box where it's
the deep side resonance but there's two
other choices for this mod slot
for other deep sight resonance or maybe
those are the tasks to unlock the perks
i'm curious to see what the grind is
with this the with unlocking all the
perks so when you finally get to craft
your weapon
they do it doesn't look like eventually
you are going to potentially be able to
make that auto rifle that might have
subsistence and rampage it might take
you a long time to have that potential
to truly get there but again
you can grind for that and you can have
a definite path it could be grindy or
you could get the random chroma rush
that i got that's got subsistence and
rampage from a number lingaram so it's
like the rng i think is going to stay
and as you guys said there are certain
places that are going to have certain
drops that you're not going to be able
to get pursuits of specific combos raids
tend to have unique weapons if they do
dungeons the same way hopefully that
type of stuff will probably be there i
think this is going to be a way for
people who have a better way to do time
investment as opposed to certain sources
where they can get a
eventually get very close to a very very
good role but it is going to be a
lengthy way to balance it out that's my
assumption but i'm i'm worried how long
the grind is for some people but also i
like the potential of
you know you play as you said we've all
put a lot of hours into these games that
we love at some point
it'd be nice if the time does get some
payoff as well
yeah
i think if the game if there is the gun
can actually be that good and if you can
actually decide the perks and all that i
feel like it's okay for the grant to be
long because then you'll only be doing
that grind a couple times for a couple
of your key weapons and then that's it
right like you're not going to do it for
every possible combination that you
could possibly have in your vault
so i i feel like that would be fair if
it takes a while
i could respect that they did also
mention exotic crafting which is minimal
so if you picture we've got random rolls
right now on our couple mission by the
way please go run those everybody your
exotic missions you have three chances
left to get an exotic roll for dead
man's tail and hawkmoon
i'm gonna get to why that's so important
but a 40 boost in damage to miners for
exotic primaries
we gonna get to that that's like we got
some big big potential but that's going
to be kind of a similar thing with
exotic crafting
is going to be more of a tweak same way
those work you're going to have some
change to the barrels or the magazine
parts but the main functionality the
weapon is going to stay there like
you're going to be able to craft the new
exotic glaives for each class maybe it
has a little faster reload maybe it has
a little less charge time those are the
tweaks you're going to be able to do but
generally i think the exotic crafting is
going to be tweaking but i think that's
their way to kind of still have the
variation of exotic random rolls without
the mess that they have right now
um we do have the new pursuit shotgun
it's going to be called reckless
endangerment i don't think we know much
more about that besides the fact that
it's a pursuit weapon
uh but the big thing i think is actually
gonna change are weapon traits and if
you look through the twab and you pick
up one of the two weapons the red
outline ones you're gonna see you got
your barrels magazines per you know perk
three and part four
the masterwork is out at column six now
and we have a fifth column of a perk and
those are going to be the new weapon
traits and traits are something they've
said
what is your way to make a
solar hand cannon any different from
another solar hand cannon whether you
get it from a strike or raid or anything
else and now these are going to be a way
for them to give weapons a minor shift
in identity and some of these actually
sound cool
because you've got to change to the
source of the weapon will determine what
benefits you can have out of it
so take trials of osiris for example
you've got the work
sorry the trait i'm going to call this
the wrong thing many times the trait
called alacrity
gain increased reload stability aim
assistant range when the last living
member of your fire team or running solo
by the way and for me i was like hey yo
okay here we go they're thinking um solo
includes solo lost sectors and rumble so
it actually gives you benefit for using
certain things as a one-off but it's 20
reload 20 stability 10 name assist 10
range
and then you've got crucible where if
you're out of combat for four seconds
you get plus 40 to reload so you're back
in the fight faster nightfall strike
sounds actually really big
uh stunning a champion you get 60 health
and plus 40 recovery for a few seconds
strikes every kill gives you a little
bit of health
and you can actually combine these so if
you get a weapon from a nightfall you're
gonna have two different traits to pick
between either the nightfall with the
big recovery boost on champions or the
vanguard one where you get the little
health boost so if you get a weapon from
strikes and you're gonna from nightfall
and you're gonna go running strikes kick
that thing over the low level benefits
and you kill a lot of enemies you're
just healing up running through the
whole time
you put that on an smg with like
subsistence and rampage now you're
starting to melt not dying a lot just
pushing forward the benefits actually
seem cool and the fact that they're
selectable seems kind of fun so are all
guns gonna have that like
all the new weapons are going to have
some type of trait
sounds like they're going to they're
going to transition they're going to
transition into a new set of weapons now
that
are generally stronger than what we have
but only in specific areas yep that's a
sunset but not sunset
but i called this i knew they were going
to bring sunset back in some way because
in their in my opinion the way they
always was talking about power creep
this is their way to slowly get us away
yeah
sorry i just want the same armor that
was just what was going through my mind
as well like they uh they obviously want
to get rid of some of the older guns
issued and now sort of going to make the
guns powerful but not more powerful
everywhere so this is like it's a pretty
uh clever way to do it actually without
pissing off your whole player base see
this is this is the the information that
uh bungie is
they've tried a lot of options and there
this is another one but they also did it
with weapon foundries as well so you've
got suros hakee amalan vice for example
and potential new foundries hakee is get
and this is the weird one i want to read
it so you guys can speculate too
this weapon deals increased damage
against vehicles
turrets i hate this one barricades and
the stasis crystals and it says turrets
include stainless steel it's like the
worst one i thought yeah
that's great you know
if i meet someone in the crucible
sitting on their sparrow i'll be able to
kill them
the effectiveness of that yeah i was
thinking about it i was like i was like
turrets i feel like you don't really see
them that often no that was like
a thing like i was like this seems like
a useless argument yeah
structures
i guess it could counter the new titan
wall the exotic gives you the stasis
i can see that but yeah it didn't seem
super useful i mean if you go double
grenades double stasis grenades with the
new warlock exotic you could also have
double turrets
it could also destroy the um
the uh reversible titan shield what's
that exotic that gets what you should do
through oh no
easier because that's a barrier i don't
know man we'll see i don't know
uh but i mean yeah you got seros plus 40
handling plus uh and 20 flinch
resistance after for six seconds after
reloading viced you get a chance for a
partial you get basically to chance at
subsistence
uh that's really good yeah and then
omalon stability is max plus 20 reload
is max plus 30 and but it reduces that
benefit the deeper you get into the
magazine so if you're reloading if
you're one of those who like [ __ ] kill
one guy and reload and kill one guy and
reload you're like a conventional
reloader okay we gotta reload half of
the crew here omlan will be your friend
a lot and i like our lives
so that's i actually
i think it's a unique twist for one this
actually shows that if this is what we
removed master working for to get these
types of things
this seems like a fair trade-off
e quick question what are we thinking
what do you think is the benefit of are
they going to get into the benefit of
actual master working weapon now if the
orb generation is gone it's going to be
changed to the mod from the last swabs
like they mostly mentioned that master
working has it's just going to be that
small stat benefit it's mostly for your
pvp guys they've stated that it's
something they will revisit later but
right now your masterwork cores also
look like their currency used in weapon
crafting
because it's going to be resonance alloy
glimmer and cores
so if you're you know swimming of course
sure you could master what work a weapon
for a smidge more range or smidge more
stability but you don't need to master
work a weapon now to have the
functionality of orbs to get the traits
it's just for the if you want to be
a little bit farther in those pvp shots
it's mostly for pvp actually at this
point
but i mean for traits for you i need to
create another foundry that lets me the
the trait on that set of weapons is that
i get to kill the ghosts
of the hive because i do not want to
walk over there
i don't to have to walk over to you
every time i kill you
we're going to see how that goes
it reminds me of uh that that kill
confirmed mode that they made yes well
you got to go pick up the bridge
that's that's what the entire sandbox is
going to be in which queen the entire
sandbox is just going to be kill
confirmed
marco can you please talk these two
awful lots if you don't do it in three
seconds they come back that's even worse
can you talk them off the ledge please
marco can you tell them that's not quite
so bad
the what the what the let's plays
no he said he would if you could tell he
said
pve with this ghost mechanic
i honestly i haven't uh seen too much
about that or read too much into it like
i honestly don't know like uh there is
some stuff
that i'm just not i'm not
the type of person to go online and look
at every single detail right now i used
to do that for the division and maybe
for like in the past for destiny as well
but i i kind of want to be surprised a
little bit here and there too don't
think about it too much nice like i
don't know i don't know we'll see i'm
just again in the same ballpark of uh
we'll see what happens and if it's going
to be a train wreck i'll be there to not
look away from
it just watch the entire train wreck um
unless exactly like with the traits
though to go back to that you actually
have the example if you get something
from gambit and an auto rifle you could
get the gambit hawkeye high impact auto
rifle where you can have the gambit perk
is invader tracker which they really
want us to play gambit or versus the
hawkeye which is the breach armaments
type thing so vader tracker means they
want us to play gambit but not well
enough to add any maps or fix the mode
we don't know what's happening though
there's going to be a gambit i'm
guessing it's next week because they'll
probably say void point 3.0 for the last
one
but no they're saving best for last
gambit's going right before witch queen
i doubt that
i doubt that i will i would you but
would you have guessed that they were
going to do weapon crafting before
gambit i yeah
i thought we'd get gambling
but we'll see uh okay
but mostly i'm still surprised that it's
like its own it's its own category like
it just feels like gambit should be
another pvp mode it could just be like
right there in the crucible section and
that's it right like it's i don't think
it deserves it it doesn't really deserve
to be its own thing
uh at all i feel like they could just
condense that with like the crucible
bounties maybe here and there like do
some stuff with that just put everything
at checks and just
let it sit there it has like what three
maps and like that's it it'll it'll get
reworked as a battle royale mode
it's been reworked like once three times
now already i remember seeing a video
years ago of uh
also from datto that the gambit is now
reworked it works in a different way we
have the gambit prime oh no we're
combining the two gambit modes like
they've tried so many things already
right it wasn't reworked it was stripped
down okay yeah they just they they uh
yeah they tried to make it less
prominent i think and less uh there's
fewer playlists and all that but yeah
but to answer your question cog um as we
move on a little bit they did mention uh
kill trackers are going to be just
intrinsic to all weapons because those
came with masterworks before so
basically does say um yes this means
master working should no longer be seen
as mandatory as we expect the plus 10
weapon stat
to only matter to dedicated pvp players
we have no specific plans for changes to
masterwork at this stage but we'll
revisit it later so that's kind of where
their clarification is it's mostly for
the little stat boost that you could get
a little bit for the adepts not quite as
mandatory and it's mostly just the pvp
try hards i think
but
i'd like to go along on this um my only
concern is for the pve
dedicated guy or the masterwork like
i don't know if there's enough incentive
then we already have our little concerns
about having to have the same element in
order to get the orb generation
for how they're changing the system
because now masterwork is taking away
the orb generation i don't know how i
feel about that all the way up i'm gonna
be honest i don't know that one i'm
gonna
travis concerned energy no i don't know
how i feel about that long term
on the pve side yeah no i mean i think a
lot of us were that way when they
announced that mod
is going i was on the opposite side yet
again
being as we're getting a little closer
on time i'm gonna try and blow through
some of the high points for the sandbox
because this does get into a lot of
nitty-gritty
um
basically fusion rifles uh the high
impact fusion rifles have not been good
they're beefing them up a little bit in
pve and slightly better in pvp
numerically though if you hit somebody
with three bolts in pvp you technically
could kill them because it's like 192
damage so that could be interesting
uh blinding
concussion grenade damage um is going to
be lowered by 25 so you won't be able to
blind and one-shot somebody in pvp
rocket launcher what about uh what about
pv there because that's where the
blinding nates are really strong at the
moment that's where are they doing
anything with that it looks normally
they will say not affected in pve and it
does look like the blinding concussion
will still function but the damage will
be less again it seems like in pvp pve
as well which yeah but the blinding is
what makes it strong you can just go
into a raid under levels and you just
you should shoot one you slide with
slideshow shoot another and then the
whole room is basically
stunned right so
um
that will be interesting there's there's
one currently that you can get with the
umbrella ingrams right where uh yep
ignition
i think yeah yeah ignition
yeah yeah that one yep
uh i feel like everybody's gonna be
using that for the raid
yeah yeah the blinding blinding is
extremely helpful at high level stuff
just to try and control a room so if you
don't have one try and find one uh
rocket launchers are gonna get little
sub families so they feel a little bit
different because some have intrinsic
tracking which is gonna be 0.95 x damage
you've got the high impact which is
staying about the same adaptive and
aggressive are getting like five percent
more damage not major changes but
they're going to be slight variations
not enough where your dps charts really
going to change that much but enough to
where they are not all the same
uh basically for snipers zoom is not
going to be quite as effective or as
much of an effect with regards to your
aim assist if you're a sniper in pvp
should be a little better pulse rifles
taking slightly too long to kill red bar
enemies in pve so they're gonna need 10
damage buff to miners which is good
because this is also going to benefit
the next piece exotic weapons
and this is one of the big ones we gotta
touch on this one for a little bit let's
get it let's get it exotic primary
weapons and trace rifles so exotic trace
rifles as well aren't sufficiently
stronger than legendaries for them to be
worth bringing into hard pve content
particularly against miners note that
this change applies to all exotics that
use primary ammo fighting lion is one
you probably might have forgot about
and includes most secondary effects i.e
perk triggered explosions
sunshine
uh glacioclasm
from heartbreak outbreak perfected ace
of spades those types of things increase
damage versus miners by 40
percent graviton lance
um is this exciting
anybody
i'm sad that you said the miners because
i
i would have loved to have an outbreak
matter for the raid again
i'll make perfect better let's go
what you're feeling mate what's your
feeling marco you're low you still you
little bum that is not made she's
included you're bumping uh i i'm just
i'm just i don't know do we uh
i guess i guess it only applied like
this would only be important to
to like grandmaster nightfalls maybe
i i feel like everywhere else the the
ads especially the miners already
dropped that when you look at them
it'll matter for day one raid yeah that
is enabled okay yeah that's true but are
you going to run a an exotic primary
just for ad clear think about how much
damage hawkmoon could do
yeah
yes i will that sounds great
especially i feel like
i feel like the most important thing is
having like enough boss damage on day
one so everybody's gonna be running yeah
but that's what your heavy slots for
right having special sure but that could
be like you have a guy running divinity
and then mm-hmm i mean who knows
divinity you have a guy running
gallahorn and then everybody else is
using legendary rocket launchers
because
marco i feel your initial disappointment
but i think we're forgetting one key
point from a trois before we get into 40
40 on the exotic from the minor damage
but remember they buffed scavenger to
coincide with exotic usage or heavy
bricks i mean finder excuse me so if you
if you use an exotic primary you will
get more as of right now you will get
more heavy bricks to drop the chance
will increase when you use the the
finder in the helmet i did not know that
okay yeah i've noticed it recently
because i've been running a little bit
more of um exactly i've been running um
you know what travelers the travelers
light sidearm the one since they dropped
this nerfed ability regeneration
i've been in my traveler's chosen bag
because that one you get kills you know
you consume the reload and then you get
the thing and i'm like damn why is all
these purple pricks all over the place
because i have the you know the
scavenger and i'm like oh yeah they buff
this so in this in conjunction with it i
can see a nice little synergy you know
going on so i'm a little excited but i
understand initially how you felt
because at first i was like but then i
remember that that prior change
uh yeah generally seems like an exciting
thing i think just to give benefit
giving a reason to use an exotic primary
weapon we need them so if they're going
to give us a benefit i'm curious how
this feels something like outbreak
glacio class if you get that group
explosion from not glacial class i'm
sorry um
what is the perk on graviton lance cryo
classic
yeah something like that
that one i think could be deadly
graviton
was overpowered for a while sunshine
crazy big explosions
gravitons back sunshine's back
like it's gonna be disgusting
thank you i'm saying it wrong cosmology
yes thank you chad thank you yep that's
chat for you can't believe people
remember the name of that perk it's one
i actually forget a lot in chat whenever
i'm talking for some reason graviton
lance just sucks at me remembering that
one weapon so they've had to remember it
a
lot
it feels like a different game yeah
remember back when graviton lance was
the best weapon in the game oh we were
yeah and we were all running faction
rallies i feel like that wasn't destiny
too that feels like a different life
been a while
uh chaperone
the passive range buff is going to get
brought back by a meter and a half
duality something similar but the damage
buff no longer clears on reload tariba
is gonna have its perk
half cleared when you switch weapons
because previously people would get the
charge up and then switch and lose the
benefit now you only have to get half of
that back so if you do have to switch
weapons it's a little bit better
um they also increase the ravenous beast
duration and increases for damaging a
player slightly ruinous effigy is going
to have its nerf undone so the the big
sphere is better i still don't know why
they did that apparently they don't know
either
illumina is gonna get brought up into a
little more of a 140 hand cannon better
range better stability thorn is not
getting touched
just lumina getting a little better use
aggro scepter that whole
empowerment perk is going to get
reworked
um uh it sounds like the super should
drain more slowly while empowered i use
that thing and it still just melts like
aggroceptor for add clear and if you
don't bro dump your super into that it
does a lot of work it is insane for
warlocks too with that uh with that that
what you call a chest that exotic chest
that keeps give you damage with um
uptime when you have your super at max
it's insane bro like that that's one of
my primary stasis builds with scepter
you could control ads like crazy isn't
that the one where you you power it up
and then you can make it like a beam for
for boss dp that weapon is like that's
one of my favorite weapons yeah i've
enjoyed it a lot dead man's tail they
reduced the catalyst hip fire the hip
fire rate of fire
lawrence driver and arbalist they
basically increased the flinch to help
with the pvp overbearingness and then
4runner the scavenger ammo is not as bad
as they thought so they're going to give
you a little bit more
anything with regards to exotic weapons
that i kind of blew through that you
guys outside of aggers but anything you
guys find yay exciting
it's all good
i finally need to get a terabyte
yeah i gotta get mines too
okay i still don't have that one
i thought i was gonna be able to buy it
from the exotic kiosk but you still need
uh can't you
yeah you can but you need some other
currency as well like uh you need to
play like the rate currency yeah
spoilers spoils
i just didn't have enough so i guess
it's finally time time to start
reading uh and then we've got legendary
weapons those are going to be
i'm trying to
copy some timestamps here ish
legendary weapons i'm not going to go
into all the nuance because this is some
nitty-gritty basically
a lot of hand cannons from 140s and 150s
were all smashed together they're
normalizing a lot of them and
aim assist is going down for most of
them a couple stats are mostly going up
the iklos smg just got punched in the
face outside of a smidge zoom and then
fell which fell winter's lie has a
bigger spread angle on its uh pellet
spread yeah
no
yes oh no that's a good thing right yeah
it was obnoxious it's obnoxious so it's
a little less i'm sad about ikelos sfg
though that was my baby the 750 then you
had the warming capabilities with that
the cell problem less range like ability
lesson
week ago and that is still the build i i
came back to with her horde and a sword
i know it's not meta anymore but it
still feels good so oh yeah oh yeah i
love seven fifty smg's
uh i'm happy that some of the aim assist
is going down though will make the pvp a
little more meaningful
yeah clean hand again in fights
yeah then we get into perks this is kind
of the next big section again i got to
go fast time wise uh if you guys have
any ones that you want me to stop on let
me know
um we've got they're allowing you to
build into hip fire more easily so
they're basically saying the falloff
distance for range on hip fire except
shotgun snipers and fusions is going to
be 20 farther so if you're hip firing
it's not quite as bad against you
adagio's getting a little bit of a buff
the duration's a little longer the
damage bonus except bows and fusions i
wish it stayed on bows is up to 30
percent uh adds 10 to range and also
they added a timer to the buff so you
can see while it's going on
uh i wanted to ask chat because i asked
other people do you guys care about dual
loader
put two shotgun shells in a shotgun at
the same time but usually the reload is
slow
seems like it changes nothing
yeah it might be like half a second
faster i don't really know
i feel like i'd prefer like the perks
like reconstruction or what is it called
something like that
reconstitution yeah all that stuff
anyway they're reducing the reload stat
penalty on dual loader from 50 minus 50
to minus 35 and i'm just like okay i
don't know if anyone who uses that
that's why i was
i was wondering it's it's
the only one i have seen who's like this
that perk is clutch i'm like if you're
using
but yeah most most people i think are
kind of like okay new rads on is gonna
stay on his island that's totally fine
danger zone um it felt pretty risky it
says in some cases i never want a
grenade launcher with danger zone
because you're like why am i going to
fire a grenade close to me well they
said they reduced the self-damage
scaling you're cool
because you're a titan
i mean it still just doesn't seem small
it's it's risky in anything high level
so there's no reason for me to build
into it combined with other scalars this
ends up self damage from 1.25 x to 0.75
x
basically just won't hurt yourself quite
as bad i still don't
all right so my two regulars in chat
love dual loader you two have fun
yeah
to no surprise on the next one if you
saw the trials report recently
tap the trigger is a meta breaking perk
on fusion rifles so
they're changing up what it does from
the stability from plus 40 to plus 10
they also changed the max recoil angel
and this is only fusion rifles this is
basically to fix main ingredient from
being a beast
changes max recoil angle almost twice as
much they change the error angle this is
all nuances but it doesn't affect
anything else basically this because
they've taken off a lot of fusions and
they said due to these changes they may
put it back on fusions in the future but
they're making it to where it's just not
the one and only fusion rifle if you
didn't get the zer roll i'm sorry but
people have been melting you with that
one and it's like the one roll so it
became egregious enough they had to do
something about it
headseeker doesn't work on aggressive
pulse rifles because it's actually too
slow of a weapon so they made it to
where that actually functions
i thought that was funny that needed to
be fixed yeah
yes eager's edge to no surprise they're
gonna make the lunge distance
uh the benefits they're gonna reduce
that by about 25 and also caps the
velocity
the main reason they stated this clearly
in bold we have a fresh raid and other
fun content coming with the witch queen
and we want to ensure we retain the
challenge behind our upcoming rewards
they don't want people to eager's edge
fly all the way across the map to beat a
boss like an encounter
look at it
you uh you glitchers ruined my halo
sword
wait wasn't that the whole point of them
introducing that sword to bring back
like sword flying
so yeah so why did it take it away you
know like because people were using it
to jump in the air and go super fast by
using the lunge and then and then
getting through like levels and stuff
and they don't want people to cheese the
raid
but they introduced that perk just for
people to jump into the air and go super
fast like that was the whole point of
that yes
that would that would hurt they really
can't make up termite
like what was the other sport called
that got nerfed that was used to be uh
used for speed runs as well the uh world
line worldwide real life skates yes so
they nerfed that and i brought that bike
this sort and now they nerfed this again
so what what did they want
bungie has never made up their mind
about any of this stuff sun setting good
sun setting bad we want to be
independent we want to do huge companies
we're not going back we're not going
back we're going forward we're going
forward they also said they're shelving
a few perks bottomless grief and
celerity are both going away from like
nightfalls and celerity basically that's
going to turn into a trait so now you're
not giving up that perk slot which is a
good thing you're going to get some of
those benefits from the origin trades
underdog which i don't think anybody
uses shield disorient and i don't think
anybody builds into that and air assault
that one i don't think i've seen in a
while i remember it i was like why and i
haven't seen that in a while but it's
officially being shelved
that's the peace celebrity forever any
any perk die harders out there that you
guys are happy or sad to see i mean tap
the trigger i think is just going to
make the pvp meta happy that's probably
the biggest one that i know of thank god
because that that main ingredient is
something else what is that like i
missed that whole part that's like
something recent the fusion rifle stuff
tap the trigger adds stability on
when you start firing well fusions
always function that way and main
ingredients a mid-level
uh fusion rifle so it's got that decent
damage and now if you and the zur
basically sold one with like tap the
trigger i don't know if it was opening
shot rain it was the perfect roll with
tap the trigger so people if they bought
it it's there it just it's mapping
people it's all not quite as bad as
aaron till but it's close which was
another fusion rifle that kind of broke
things too far
so it's it's the one weapon right now
that has that perk combination and then
zur sold it and
made a fusion rifle topped the most
kills in trials last weekend
right okay so it's just a combination of
a couple of perks and stats nothing's
actually not working as intended it's
just that it's working a bit too well
yeah exactly okay gotchu gotcha yeah
it's it's a it's a perk combination
that's on an older weapon
you haven't been able to get it in a
while but yeah it's that that one-off
happened from zur they even talked about
squid face
yeah uh
what sorry no go ahead no i was just
gonna say i'm excited for um
using pulses in pve again i felt
pulses just didn't have a good place and
i know you yeah it's good okay talk your
dad by a gun talk that gold figure let's
go this rifle adapt you would at least
it's not an auto rifle at least it's not
an auto rifle
and i can't and they even took out the
archetype of go figure and blast furnace
they don't that's not in the game
anymore they don't have any makeup yeah
the was it the four bursts mm-hmm
that was my favorite
yeah i was just gonna say because i got
like a a couple of legal actions on
standby
i i want to use aggressive pulses again
you know cold denial and all that stuff
and you know i just felt i just were in
a good place i would just take a 600 i
would even prefer using an smg over a
pulse like it just wasn't it didn't feel
good so the 40 for me is gonna feel good
and then also
you know exotics like this is gonna
change the game like the way
we play and if that synergy with the
miners combined with the heavy ammo it
should be it should be it should be
substantial so that we don't always
crutch on the highest dps
exotic heavies all the time you know so
we'll see we'll see how it plays out i
actually remember trying to farm a
perfectly rolled right side of wrong by
doing a loss sector on mars over and
over again
because
i thought that that was gonna be a
necessary weapon to have for the day one
garden of salvation and i spent that is
probably the most time i ever spent
farming a weapon and i never got a good
roll but i have
four good go figures but they weren't
elemental damage right yeah like they uh
they were kinetic
and so
you needed elemental as well for the for
the raid i guess because she needed a
good but then pulses ended up being
pretty bad in that era so
i did it all for nothing anyway and now
i think it's sunset
so yeah yep so now i can't like
i never got to
all that time just wasted
uh for the new future they do and this
will excite most of this crew for season
17 so the season that launches after
which queen don't know the length of the
season everybody assumes it'll be about
three months in season 17 we'll have a
set of pvp-focused weapon changes
including
they're like i'm sorry excuse me excuse
me excuse me
new ways for players to build for flinch
resistance
balance tuning for primary weapons
looking and shoot pulse rifles
lightweight in particular
balance weapon tuning snapshot feeling
mandatory on sniper rifles in pvp other
balance changes
another pvp special ammo economy change
that is something they mentioned
basically pvp you're only going to drop
one
ammo
from your brick
and then scavengers might be too if
you're on scavenger but you're not going
to be able to run around and pick up
three and it's going to they're trying
to help the special aim economy not just
snowball quite as much
um they also said adjusting how zoom
outliers picture like the multi-mock if
you get the right scope on it that thing
can basically work like an auto rifle so
they're gonna probably normalize some of
those is what it sounds like and also
we're adjusting several much requested
exotics
along with legendary perks so more
exotic adjustments coming with so flinch
resistance and um
like easier to land shots on low zoom
snipers because more aim assist yep
gonna be interesting how that works out
yeah that sounds a little scary i mean
for me though on the other side it's
like building into flinch resistance i
hope that means you actually can flinch
someone if they don't build into it
because there are things right now if
you can sit there and hit somebody three
times and they're still somewhat able to
hit that one one off headshot it seems a
little not right so i would be happy if
you have to lead into it yeah i'd be
happy if you have to lean into flinch
resistance but flinch is higher if you
don't
right what if uh there are certain mods
on armor and they take up the spot of
the scavenger mods and so you can build
into flames resistance but then you
can't
like have as much sniper ammo on them
see that makes perfect sense look at
look at marco just calling a shot right
there don't get ivanta started on armor
stuff you're talking about right now you
know yeah trust me bring your division
army energy into lightfall i want like
armor crafting 3.0 like lightfall i'm
because it's not happening right now but
yeah my hope is for something cool and
armor later on
yeah actually make builds matter and
then have loadouts too
yes please loadouts uh set bonuses we
got teased with that one time um
gambit yeah so
no i missed set bonuses that's what i
was like from division that's one of the
things that i missed the set bonuses
in just any game with set bonuses even
diablo hell yes uh the final thing is
the downtime before which queen launches
you have 14 hours of server downtime
it's going to be down from 7 00 a.m or 7
p.m pacific until 9 00 a.m pacific it's
kind of next day
if uh beyond light is any indication of
how this is gonna go we're gonna be
sitting in the menus for hours after the
launch yeah i'm honestly i can't decide
because i know
i need a raid i need i'm gonna do a day
one raid i know i'm gonna stream i know
of that content but also i'm like do i
just set my alarm like an hour or two
later if i can like push my sleep that
far because the servers are gonna suck
there are a million
pre-orders for witch queen
if half of those people try and log in
on
day one you may as well just shut it
down
yeah i know i think i'm just gonna play
on day two i i'm not in a rush i'm not
looking to take time you take date you
take the day after off take the
wednesday
this boy
i mean trav's right though and it says
that this ain't our first rodeo we know
the vibe that first date they're gonna
get killed with the service i'm gonna
wait for the dust to settle come in
either later on that night or the next
day and then really go at it you know
kind of thing but
people get prepared for the q numbers
your your number 10 000 in line i'd be
lucky if you're that low
yeah
it's going to be crazy but yeah i agree
i agree a heads up to all your sony
playstation copy files
the preload for which queen is planned
to become available on all platforms at
9 00 pm pacific so that's midnight
eastern time depending on where you're
at in the world if you got to set your
alarm get up start the download and go
back to sleep whatever you got to do you
have 12 hours to download the update
servers will be down for a while but
you'll have 12 hours to download the
update servers are going to be down that
being said iron banner is the final week
don't think you can play iron banner
until the wee hours of the morning and
sleep game's going to be off so plan
ahead for that final week get your stuff
done beforehand
as you're they're going to have their
extended downtime
other than that they've kind of covered
everything else they said you know like
shattered realm was on a daily rotation
if you need to do those you can do them
on a daily rotation there are certain
weapons cycling out of the ritual
rewards pool we've covered most of this
stuff before
and the final two swabs that we've
basically got left are going to be void
3.0 which is still going to be probably
big until we get our hands on it's
mostly going to be reworking but we'll
see and then also whatever this gambit
rework is
um
so with regards to gambit yeah
gambit gambit
this is what you're focusing on focusing
on bungie yeah what if it's late now
it'll be funny right
i just i'm just hoping for a mobile
bubble with voice 3.0 that's that's what
i'm looking for right here
i'm hoping that the gambit update is
just the shortest swap we've ever gotten
and you open it and it just says you've
deleted gambit
we've removed gambit from the game and
that's the whole update
after careful consideration we our data
showed no one's playing the ball
yeah it's like you don't need data for
that one sadly
um
as you guys are now seeing a lot of
these changes that they're making i
where do you guys feel when we don't
have void 3.0 and gambit's gambit we'll
see how that goes but i mean void we
kind of know that's going to be a rework
a little more customization in the
subclass but this is
one of the biggest substantial changes
that's coming for as we kind of wrap up
where do you guys where's your hype
level at this point we're a couple weeks
out
you know we got two more swabs left to
go couple more podcasts before we get
going where are you guys at with regards
to witch queen
is there any big thing that you're
worried about is there any big thing you
still gotta see or you just like hype
train full speed ahead
i'm not i'm really just hoping that
they're that they can change up the
formula enough from the past dlcs to
where it's it's actually interesting
enough and i can see past oh we're doing
the story now okay now we're doing the
light level and now we're doing the raid
and that's it right like i hope there's
a there's a little more
a little more to it because i felt that
even with beyond light and i even
haven't played i haven't even played all
the expansions i haven't been a destiny
2 player for that long not as long as
you guys
and i feel that everything they've put
out every year has been extremely
formulaic
so
i'm just hoping that they can change up
the formula of course still keep it
destiny but
give me something i haven't seen yet
even while doing the story and keep me
engaged that way
but that sort of hopes i'm not i don't
really know i'm not super hyped i'm just
gonna wait and see and see what they can
bring me this year
travis how jim oh [ __ ]
i'm uh
i'm
somewhat hyped i mean
to me it is work i'm gonna be reviewing
uh witch queen so uh i'm sort of i'm
sort of bracing for the the coming grind
and getting it done but i love destiny
i've been playing it for seven years and
reviewing it that whole time so it's
always like a staple in my
uh life when this this comes around and
everyone who knows me in my personal
life hates me or just doesn't hear from
me uh for a while after new content
comes out that said i haven't i don't
think bungie's done a great job at
building hype uh so far i feel like they
kind of let a little too much go early
and a lot of that hype has died down and
then the fact that there's absolutely no
story happening in the game and we're
two weeks out they haven't finished
season the lost or anything like that i
also feel it's like really bad so maybe
maybe these next two weeks they have a
whole bunch
of stuff that we don't know about yet
that's gonna rebuild hype but i feel
like the train kind of slowed down in
terms of the hype that they're building
if we if they were still doing
monologues from sabbath through now if
they had moved all that stuff over can
you imagine how crazy the hype would be
right now but i feel like that that's
that's in the ancient history as far as
everybody else is concerned so i
actually played that last week
so for me
that's perfect honestly you have the
ideal situation because we can't even
really remember sabathune got put into
storage i also have a dialogue disabled
somewhere so i also have a dialogue
disabled so there's that but i actually
did that last week to get back in it so
for me it works out perfectly though
that's great yeah i know i feel like if
that were happening now for like most
players the hype would be a lot higher
but i do feel like it's a little bit
lower um we'll see what comes the next
two weeks but obviously i'm stoked that
i'm going to be playing a whole lot of
destiny and i'm really glad i got
done with all of my destiny stuff and
kind of get to take this month break uh
from everything i got the seal by the
way for uh dares of eternity 35 bursary
because usually i don't go for them
yeah yeah yeah which i mean um
it it does
i feel i think uh tassie said this
online that it feels different i feel
like bungie is still holding on to
something because it doesn't feel like
the normal hype cycle for
the biggest expansion you know that they
got going i mean we're getting up we're
getting we're getting content but we get
a lot of stuff early so it's like if
you're giving us all of this this early
my hope is they're still holding on to
some key things you know maybe i'm
optimistic there so what do you think it
might be what do you what do you i have
a theory and it's it's totally a wrong
theory like they're completely incorrect
but i have it there i have a theory that
uh that that the um the poison element
is in this dlc
yeah that's my theory i i it's like it
almost feels like that new subclass
slash class energy because
it's i know i know i'm with you no way
but that's just what i feel like i don't
know what i feel like
something
because like normally
the old cadence
we'd get a stuff like this a little this
would be like the week before going in
like we're getting this so it's like
we're getting this now and let's be
honest give it ain't big enough to be
you know like for them to say yo we
still get so it's like you you got more
and i i i don't want to get too excited
i know i'm gonna let you go marco i i
just it feels a little different so part
of me feels that there is a big secret
that they don't want to reveal yet and
they're gonna wait until the story that
you're catching up on now with savithoon
that you have the text and things muted
but the story that you know what once it
now concludes and then we get to the
moment how cybertune gets into power
yada yada then they go ha ha
and then maybe we go whoa because i'm
still waiting for that
yo mama i don't feel i've had it yet
which is weird for which queen but
that's how i feel but marco and e
and michael wanted to say something no i
i i don't think that's going to happen
i think that one moment
i think that one moment is going to be
the raid but they might have like a
special mission in it or or something
like that but
i just don't see it happening i feel
like what they've shown so far is
already like a pretty good expansion
like a good size right
yeah i i'm kind of with you that they
usually they usually tell us everything
and then we're just not really surprised
like i feel like they did that with
beyond light a lot and worked against
them but i always have that glimmer of
hope that there's like the dreaming city
you know that we didn't know about some
location we don't know about so the
dreaming city was completely
maybe the raid finally introduces the
darkness uh
as an enemy type or something like that
like i'm just i'm hoping that's like the
the kid in me but like the reviewer who
knows how the industry works is like no
way like they would have shown us that
for sure if it was in the game see
but but uh so so one last question i
have the dream city was completely
unknown to anybody uh before people yes
oh yeah yeah that was a
huge quote unquote leaked or revealed
that kate was going to die and everybody
was like oh that's crazy and then they
used that exactly
what a misdirection
that's the first thing that happened in
the season and then they had to like
that's a really cool way to do it and i
did an on-site review for that game i
went to bungie hq and got to play it
like you know a couple weeks before it
was out and they didn't even show us the
dreaming scene right that's how crazy it
was like i had beaten the campaign and
still not seen the dreaming city right
so yeah they they they do some stuff
they're not afraid to to surprise people
i'm curious what he thinks uh i mean for
me i kept saying when's the story gonna
finally end
february 8th is still holding very
accurate at this point so sadly the
lunar new year and the astral alignment
in real life didn't quite tie in which
would have kind of been cool but i get
it two weeks before to have the
savathoon
if it's not on the 8th it's going to be
like when servers go down like the day
before which i still don't expect they
would really do a live event so i expect
the story next week and i'm wondering if
when the story drops when you get done
if all of a sudden they say hey there's
now this countdown for a video on bungie
on youtube that's going to go live
that's either a vidoc or a youtube video
that's where i expect as you said like
the hype's kind of been these little
20-second teasers everywhere like here's
a little story here's a little story
here's this person talking here's this
person talking
we haven't finished the last story she
hasn't come out of her chrysalis we
haven't had that moment that pushes us
to which queen and we're basically two
weeks away so i feel like tuesday's
gotta be that moment because i don't
think they would do it at the same time
iron banners there which would just seem
weird
so you're gonna have hopefully that
moment and then i've got to assume a
little deeper trailer or maybe a vidoc
if they want to give a little more
behind the scenes i don't know if it's
too close for a vidoc but maybe they
could do something like that that's
that's what i would hope at this point
if they don't do that then they i think
they really have just chosen to keep
their cards close to their chest
because normally if it's not in that two
if it's not tuesday
they're they're just keeping the secrets
this time
is my assumption um i'm excited though
because the campaign sounds like they're
gonna have
they've they've talked about more of
their unique missions and the exotic
missions they're talking about how
campaign is going to have more of that
feel more mecha i think the campaign is
going to be something special and if you
and if they can connect it to the raid
and if savathun doesn't die two big ifs
but if they can do those two and have
unique mechanics and fun story missions
and almost feeling like some of our
one-off exotic missions that we've had
if they can do that
and as you guys have said if there's
some cool surprises we don't know about
i think it is going to be
some of the same as marco's worried
about because the power leveling seems
to generally be
soft cap power cap hard cap all of those
seem to be there which is unfortunate
because
i would like to see some shifting there
but it doesn't seem to happen but it
does seem with weapon crafting we're
gonna have different pursuits
uh with just spending more time with
these weapons we may still hate strikes
doing it which is unfortunate
but again
some happiness
some that we already probably expect to
be about the same i'm just hoping kind
of like you cog if they
if we don't know as much as we do now
and we're waiting on void 3.0 which we
have the subclass just gonna work a
little differently and gambit what do we
not know
yeah so i'm with you
i'm sorry no it's like i'm with you on
that one no that's one time i i will say
this though the excitement for me right
now and i think marco appreciate it just
that
you know as much as it is the ritual the
routine sometimes we roll our eyes all
right the power level ground we know
there is that fun is there's something
about
world's first destiny
raid unknown
and just not you know just getting that
hype train going you get your raid team
together you know and you just attacked
that thing and i'm looking forward to
that i want to know that is the main
reason that i want to play the dlc as
well it's just for that rate just it's
going to be like 10 hours and it's going
to be like the craziest thing ever yeah
like that's that's why i play destiny
like that is the biggest reason
basically i don't really care about
getting all the god rules my whole vault
i've got like [ __ ] blue stuff in my
fault still
because i just put it in there when i
started playing the game and i never
cared enough to take it out right um
it's just like that is the reason i play
destiny that's why i grind the gear i
like every year i get my gear my build
specifically for the raid and then the
rest of the year it just kind of like
drops off because i i have no reason to
get a build anymore right so it's yeah
that is their reason to play
yeah that that's that's always been my
hook that's what kept me in destiny as
well you know for the vaulted glass days
to now and um yeah it's just that
unknown and looking at okay where's
travis his team where they at in the
encounter or where did they learn oh
damn they're ahead of us they figured
those plates out in that pocket all
right
it's just that that game within the game
and then there's let's be honest there's
the joy even though you know when you
see i've never been with for but like
when you see someone a team do it
and that genuine joy of them being world
first like i remember last wish i forgot
that team's name and i was like
yeah yeah yeah you they felt it like you
seen it it's just it's something that
you see bungie like 18 hours right like
18 hours and then that came in seconds
with uh just uh just after yeah
the meme will live forever nope yeah
yeah it's so cool and then you see
budgie get behind you see them in the
studios watching all the tv it's it's a
thing man it's an event i i still feel
no game i still stand on my square in
console it's still probably
the best cooperative activity i've ever
played for me that that gives me the
most right that's why i still love race
it's the best content they they make and
i think more people need which last word
host is going to beat the raid first
you
you confidence come on e what do you
think
oh he got them all stars that's right i
mean i got a good group but honestly
like i'm happy
of who i'm with especially like i heard
cool guy talking on firing range he
wants to like make sure you know get up
walk around every hour have your food
i'm in for the time investment to get
the day one
and again we're trying to be like hey
try the encounter a little bit blind get
a feel for it but if we go see what
other people are doing then it's like if
we get stuck check out go look at other
strats i'm not trying to go totally
blind i'm tr we're trying to finish it
but in a healthy way
so
i think got it
i'm trying to fall on the sword and just
kill myself beating the right there you
go so that's why i'm not gonna say me
because i think we're trying to
helpfully get the day one finish not the
day not really steady though you might
we might do it i mean like if you pace
yourself sometimes that's the way to go
i was like every time we have a day one
raid it's been super unhealthy it's just
a nonstop caffeine grinds until like
just non-stop
yep well as we are i was going to say as
we are getting tight on time especially
for cog uh i do want to wrap this up but
first i want to say marco thank you for
joining us this morning i know travis
had to get up early but you are you're
the guest coming from very far away so
we thank you for joining us this morning
um hey man that was all fun glad you
always glad you enjoyed it uh at this
point this is kind of the time for you
to tell anybody who hears this and all
the places that they're gonna hear it
where to find you where to find your
content what type of content you do just
any and all that stuff just where they
can look you up and be like all right
that guy sounded like he had something
to listen to where do we find him
uh i mean i guess you could look at my
youtube some of my destiny videos but i
i haven't really posted anything destiny
for for a long time now
uh
like what are you posting yeah
it's um you know you can probably find
me on youtube or twitter somewhere but
i'm not super active at the moment so
this is not uh we don't need to do the
whole shout out thing right now just
maybe
what are you playing then if you're not
playing destiny what game what are you
getting into so right now i'm not really
playing too much i've actually like the
last two months i've been working on the
video oh you're living real life okay
that's boring oh i've actually been
editing for like 10 hours a day straight
on average
and then the weekends doing something
like
maybe playing a little bit of this or a
little bit of that but nothing serious
it's just been
like i'm just i've been trying to
experiment my content a lot and so
i've been doing that instead of playing
video games
got it hey look at you being an adult
wait a way to be yeah yeah he's becoming
a dj guys yeah it's his new zack ii
i also enjoy it more than just playing
so it's like i get to be creative
instead of just grinding out strikes so
i feel like that's
more enjoyable for me it's it's good to
mix it up i'll never grant that keeps it
healthy you can't make
demarco style man absolute legend you
know i i'm so happy that you were able
to come on when he told me that you you
you're coming on i was like fanboy and i
was like oh man like my dude like i used
to watch your videos brother like and
consistently and you know your
analytical approach you know to division
and i always felt
you know destiny could learn so much
from them as much as the division
fanboys and me would go at it we throw a
little jabs at each other but it was fun
and we we really appreciate that and
then to see i remember when you you
started playing that's i'm like what is
this like i couldn't believe it then
you're like i don't know if i'm gonna
stick with it and then you kind of stuck
with it and then you did your first raid
and i was like oh he's got the fever now
and i started to see the transformation
but i love what you said in reference to
taking a step back and enjoying
something because you want to do it not
and that doesn't necessarily coincide
with financial stuff all the time right
but if you're not happy
yeah to me i'm always about the content
creator's overall health and his
happiness and if that's what giving you
joy by all means do what you got to do
you're a legend out here good to have
you last we got to get you back one time
but um yeah man this is this is fun and
and a lot of stuff to talk about but uh
yeah man with me you already know what
cognito on twitter i lost podcast on
youtube defining duke check yes
super chat by the way since it seems
like it's dirty oh my god
let's get it let's get it let's get it
dj dj oros hey guys i gotta get on yeah
can i read this yeah because it's
directed at me
uh david james oros of the pennsylvania
area i believe uh
for five dollar super chat says hey guys
long time listener and fan just wanted
to say thanks for the entertaining
friday morning most of your views are
great keep up the toxicity
that's a shot um i don't know we all
know who he's sub tweeting at you know
uh david you should probably listen to
the early part of the podcast and uh
pete parsons will be over tomorrow
morning for your wake-up call so uh
yeah uh good times um i guess i'll do my
stuff now um yeah you can uh read my
review of dying light 2. i played uh
about 100 hours of that game uh the past
couple weeks um i gave it a seven out of
ten spoiler alert i liked it a lot but
it's got a lot of bugs that you're
probably gonna have to go oh wait now
what's that review
nice
i did i did that's all guys
yeah that review like a couple days ago
i think one day ago yesterday two days
yeah here thank you yeah i did yes that
was my review that's my voice on that um
i didn't know up until now
he's kind of famous
i'm not famous but my reviews are i'll
post on twitter
and i'll do a ign review and it'll get
like 15 million views i'm like all right
people know my reviews and not me
um
yeah uh so yeah you can uh you can find
me on twitter ty guy travis uh this uh
sunday i'm doing a bit cast episode
where we're talking about lots of stuff
uh we also have a new uh host on that
show oh yeah richard ho of hoglaw is
going to be joining us on our as a as a
permanent member um so we are
certainly going to um going to talk
about the bungee acquisition and stuff
if you want to hear me uh yet again get
on my soapbox and die tribe about that
uh and then uh yeah just
go to igen.com read my stuff i got a
preview of a game i can't talk about uh
that will come out on february 10th and
then i'm reviewing crossfire x and
destiny the witch queen this month so uh
get ready for for those um
and uh
yeah you shot me into finding duke nice
talking anyway
oh bro i'll get you don't worry about
working we'll get e and a two don't
worry
yeah again we just want to say thank you
to marco for coming out um for travis
for waking up cog for fitness fitting us
into your morning and for everybody in
chat all of you guys have been amazing
this morning thank you guys chat was
absolutely on fire and hilarious always
keeps us uh entertained and going and
whether you would listen to this on
audio whether it's itunes spotify if
you'll drop us a review those are always
helpful if you find us on youtube uh
whether it's on my channel or iron
lord's podcast channel please subscribe
like follow all the good things there
and follow all of these amazing creators
i mean travis cognito marco style
entertainment hot takes and telling you
what you
need to hear
you got you got a great group here so i
just want to say thank you all for being
here this morning it's you know it's
been an early morning but it's been a
hilarious and definitely we woke up
early to get this podcast started so
thank you for basically reading the
whole swap for me that is
that is why we are here sir we let our
guests know the information they would
rather not have to read through so we do
it for you
no but seriously thank you for uh
joining us it was absolutely our
pleasure but that is where we're gonna
wrap up this episode so chat you guys
have been awesome
guests of course thank you um and hosts
of course we can't do this without all
of you guys here and of course all of
the viewers again thank you very much
but for episode number 183 we are
creeping close to 200. we are going to
wrap this thing up so as we do we're
going to do it the way we always do for
episode 183 it has been
oh [ __ ] i forgot last word
oh
can we just keep it like this i feel
like this is perfect
so perfect all right everybody we'll see
you soon